This is the 99% invisible breakdown of the power broker. I'm Roman Mars. And I'm Elliot Kalem. On today's episode, we're covering part three, the rise to power. That's pages 91 through 177 in my copy with some nice glossy photos in the middle there. And our guest is esteemed historian, New York Times opinion columnist and TikTok superstar, Jamel Buoy. And when we first came up with this series, I knew I wanted to have Jamel on because he is so great at contextualizing history and
这是《99%隐形》对《权力掮客》的深度解析。我是罗曼·马尔斯。我是埃利奥特·卡勒姆。在今天的节目中，我们将讨论第三部分：权力的崛起。在我手头的版本中，这部分涵盖了第91页到第177页，中间还有一些精美的光面照片。我们的嘉宾是备受尊敬的历史学家、《纽约时报》评论专栏作家兼TikTok超级明星贾梅尔·布伊。当我们最初构思这个系列时，我就知道我想邀请贾梅尔，因为他非常擅长将历史语境化，并
connecting the past to the present. So thank you for being here. It's my pleasure. Now, I should warn the audience ahead of time, Jamel has not actually read the Power Broker. That's okay. That's okay. It's like a lot of you. You haven't read it either. He hasn't read it. This is his first true exposure to the book. And I couldn't be prouder that Roman and I get to deflower him in this way. Just when it comes to the power broker.
将过去与现在联系起来。所以，感谢你的到来。这是我的荣幸。现在，我得提前警告听众，贾梅尔其实并没有读过《权力掮客》。没关系，没关系。这就像你们中的许多人一样，你们也没读过。他没读过。这是他第一次真正接触这本书。我感到无比自豪，因为罗曼和我能以这种方式让他“破处”。我是说，就《权力掮客》这本书而言。
But Jamele knows so much about this time period that we're covering. We're gonna bring him in periodically just to help us get a sense of what was going on at that time, what's the context that this power is being broken in? That's right. So let's just start what we left off last time. At the end of Chapter 5, it's November, it's 1918, Robert Moses is about to turn 30. His career in public service has almost ended at this point. Like he's complete failure. All of his different programs he has
但贾梅尔对我们所涵盖的这段时期非常了解。我们将定期邀请他加入，帮助我们了解当时发生了什么，以及这种权力是在什么样的背景下被打破的？没错。那么，让我们从上次结束的地方开始。在第五章结尾，时间是1918年11月，罗伯特·摩西即将满30岁。此时他的公共服务生涯几乎已经结束了。他简直是个彻底的失败者。他提出的所有不同方案都
proposed have failed. But then he gets a call from his former boss's wife, Bel Moskowitz. So tell me, Elliot, who is Bel Moskowitz? Okay, here's one of the amazing things about the Power Broker. Jamal, now my whole mission in this episode is just to sell this book to you directly at Hardcore One-on-One. This is one of the great things about this book
失败了。但随后他接到了他前任老板的妻子贝尔·莫斯科维茨的电话。那么告诉我，埃利奥特，贝尔·莫斯科维茨是谁？好吧，《权力掮客》最神奇的地方之一就在这里。贾梅尔，现在我这期节目的全部使命就是直接向你推销这本书，进行硬核的一对一交流。这本书最伟大的地方之一
is that it is about Robert Moses. It's his face on the cover. It's his name in the subtitle. But there's so many things that Robert Carroll can't help going into detail about, and that's often the lives of the people who are important to Moses' rise and Moses' career. And in the case of Bill Moskowitz, this is someone who, without the power broker, their story may have disappeared, possibly. They may not have ever gotten the treatment they deserved because she is this unassuming kind of behind the scenes operator.
在于它虽然是关于罗伯特·摩西的。封面是他的脸，副标题是他的名字。但罗伯特·卡罗忍不住详细描述了太多事情，而这些往往是那些对摩西的崛起和摩西的职业生涯至关重要的人的生活。就贝尔·莫斯科维茨而言，如果没有《权力掮客》，她的故事可能早就消失了。她可能永远不会得到她应得的关注，因为她是一个谦逊的、幕后操盘手式的人物。
She's not a government official, but she is an activist and she's a determined activist, but she's also a very realistic activist in the reform movement of the late 19th century, early 20th century. And she is going to become the most trusted advisor of New York Governor, Al Smith, who will be a major person in the life of Robert Moses. And she is, Al Smith, he always first wore his Mrs. M, and he asked her opinion on everything. Carol depicts her as literally the last person that he will talk to before he makes a decision, and he'll usually go with whatever she says in the decision making. And all the Irish political bosses, they really resent her
她不是政府官员，但她是一位积极分子，而且是一位坚定的积极分子，但她也是19世纪末20世纪初改革运动中非常现实的积极分子。她后来成为了纽约州州长阿尔·史密斯最信任的顾问，而阿尔·史密斯将成为罗伯特·摩西生命中的重要人物。她是阿尔·史密斯的“M夫人”，他事事都会征求她的意见。卡罗将她描绘成他在做决定前交谈的最后一个人，而且他通常会采纳她提出的任何决定。所有的爱尔兰政治大佬们，他们真的非常怨恨她，
and they call her Mosque behind her back and very derisively as a sort of anti-Semitic nickname that I will say as someone who's willing to find anti-Semitism just about anywhere, Mosque is a pretty good nickname for someone named Mosque. It's like, I don't know, it's pretty natural. So, but I'll go very quickly through her life. She's the daughter of a poor Eastern European watchmaker
他们在背后非常刻薄地称她为“Mosque”（清真寺），这是一种反犹太主义的绰号。作为一个愿意在任何地方寻找反犹太主义的人，我会说，对于一个姓Mosque的人来说，这确实是个挺贴切的绰号。就像，我不知道，这很自然。所以，我会很快讲完她的一生。她是东欧一位贫穷钟表匠的女儿，
She comes from a different New York Jewish background than Moses does she gets involved with the settlement house movement Which was one of the big, you know Reform progressive movements. Maybe Jim. I'll do can you tell me a little bit more about the settlement house movement? Cuz I only know vaguely what was going on with it. I probably don't know any more than you do I know the term settlement house. My main understanding is that there is a major concern for crime and poverty among urban youth. And so this was one of the ideas, especially in slums, basically. We can have these homes that can offer programs, offer places for people to live, you know, place for people to live, like a space that is conducive to, you know, developing human talents. And that's the extent of my knowledge there.
她有着与摩西不同的纽约犹太背景。她参与了睦邻之家运动，这是当时重大的改革进步运动之一。也许贾梅尔，你能多告诉我一点关于睦邻之家运动的事吗？因为我只模糊地知道那是怎么回事。我可能知道的并不比你多。我知道“睦邻之家”这个词。我的主要理解是，当时人们对城市青年的犯罪和贫困问题非常担忧。所以这是当时的想法之一，特别是在贫民窟里。我们可以建立这些家园，提供项目，提供人们居住的地方，你知道，提供人们居住的地方，就像一个有助于发展人类才能的空间。这就是我所知道的全部了。
That's a great description. You started out modest, became in strong at the end. So I think that worked out great. She studies at Columbia University, and her second husband is the social worker Henry Moskowitz we met in the last episode running the Bureau of Municipal Research that Moses worked for. She's real reform circle royalty. Like she's a major figure in the New York reform circuit. One of the reasons for that is because she succeeded in cleaning up what they called the Dancing Academies, which were essentially sex trafficking spots, but were presented as Dancing Academies for young ladies, but were places where young ladies were then preyed upon. And she cleans them up, not the way that other reformers might have with like a big public movement or by bringing publicity to the problem.
那是一个很棒的描述。你开始时很谦虚，最后却说得很强有力。所以我认为这很棒。她在哥伦比亚大学学习，她的第二任丈夫是社会工作者亨利·莫斯科维茨，我们在上一集里见过他，他经营着摩西工作的市政研究局。她是真正的改革圈贵族。她是纽约改革圈的重要人物。原因之一是她成功清理了所谓的“舞蹈学院”，这些地方本质上是性交易场所，但却以年轻女士的舞蹈学院为幌子，实际上是年轻女士被猎食的地方。她清理了这些地方，不是像其他改革者那样通过大规模的公众运动或将问题公之于众，
Instead, she does what Robert Carroll loves whenever anybody does. She does the research. She goes to the titles and things for these buildings, the ownership documents. She sees their owned by people in Tammany political circles. And she goes to those people and says, if you pass legislation and then enforce it that regulates these things, I won't go to the newspapers and publicize your name. She's willing to kind of work with people to get things done. And she has made an arbitrator in the arguments between the garment workers union and their bosses. And she kind of wins over both sides because she's able to play the game. She knows how to work for a common goal between them without alienating the people
相反，她做了罗伯特·卡罗最喜欢别人做的事。她做了调查。她去查了这些建筑的产权和相关文件，也就是所有权文件。她发现这些建筑是由坦慕尼协会政治圈的人拥有的。她找到这些人说，如果你通过立法并执行相关规定，我就不会去报社曝光你们的名字。她愿意通过与人合作来完成事情。她还成为了服装工人工会与其老板之间争端的仲裁者。她赢得了双方的信任，因为她懂得如何玩转游戏。她知道如何在不疏远当权者的情况下，为他们之间的共同目标而努力。
in power. They come to really trust her. They trust their blackmailer. Yes. Yeah. Well, I think there's a certain amount of like, well, you know, playing the game. This is how we do it around here. This is, you know, it's the early 20th century. We don't really have a lot of rules these days. She offers Moses a job as the chief of staff for a commission in the governor's office to design a reorganization plan for the state government and a kind of general implementation plan
他们开始真正信任她。他们信任他们的勒索者。是的。嗯，我想这在某种程度上是“玩转游戏”。这就是我们在这里做事的方式。这是20世纪初，我们现在并没有太多的规则。她给了摩西一份工作，担任州长办公室一个委员会的幕僚长，负责设计州政府的重组计划，以及一种通用的社会福利改革
for social welfare reforms. And he's like, yes, of course. I think he cannot agree fast enough because again, he thinks he has had no shot in government anymore after this. And he opens an office instantly. He starts, Carol makes a point of saying that he starts hiring people from the Bureau of Municipal Research, the guys who used to look down on him. Now he's going to be their boss. And Robert Moses never knows why Mrs. Moskowitz picks him. Never knows why Bill Moskowitz chooses him of all people. But it is the major turning
实施计划。他当时就说，是的，当然。我想他同意得不能再快了，因为他再次认为，在这之后他在政府里已经没有机会了。他立刻开设了办公室。他开始，卡罗特别指出，他开始从市政研究局雇人，那些曾经看不起他的家伙。现在他要成为他们的老板了。罗伯特·摩西永远不知道为什么莫斯科维茨夫人会选中他。永远不知道为什么贝尔·莫斯科维茨在所有人中偏偏选中了他。但这确实是他公共职业生涯中的重大转折点，
point, you could say, in his public career because it puts him into contact with Governor Al Smith, who Carol goes into it a little bit here, but there's going to be more about him later. So don't worry, we're going to get into more detail with Al Smith. But he is essentially, as Carol puts it, perhaps like the greatest pure politician in the history of New York state. And he is seen by outsiders as a real Tammany hack, but a few reformers are like, you know what, I'm at this guy. He seems like he could be useful. He maybe he'll be okay. I'm not going to talk about it too much more because you know what, there's a big section on it in the next chapter. We're going to get to that chapter next.
因为这让他接触到了阿尔·史密斯州长，卡罗在这里稍微提了一下，但后面会有更多关于他的内容。所以别担心，我们会更详细地了解阿尔·史密斯。但正如卡罗所言，他本质上可能是纽约州历史上最伟大的纯粹政治家。他被外人视为一个真正的坦慕尼协会政客，但一些改革者却说，你知道吗，我支持这家伙。他看起来可能很有用。也许他会没事的。我不会再多谈了，因为你知道，下一章有很大一部分内容是关于他的。我们接下来就要讲那一章。
This is one of the things that Robert Carroll does in this book, which is a little confusing sometimes, is he kind of like plays with the timeline in ways that give you information when he thinks it is more necessary for you, but sometimes can make it hard to keep things in your mind. So at this moment, Governor Al Smith is governor. In the next chapter, we're going to jump back and tell you the entire life story of Governor Al Smith. This is not a totally chronological book. This is a real Christopher Nolan's Dunkirk of a biography. Yeah.
这是罗伯特·卡罗在书中做的事情之一，有时会让人有点困惑，他有点像是在玩弄时间线，在认为你更需要的时候给你信息，但有时这会让你很难记住事情。所以此时，阿尔·史密斯是州长。在下一章，我们将跳回去讲述阿尔·史密斯的一生故事。这不是一本完全按时间顺序排列的书。这简直是一部克里斯托弗·诺兰《敦刻尔克》式的传记。是的。
I guess I said Dunkirk as if his other movies are purely linear. It's a little jarred, but we'll get to that. So one of the key things that Belle Motsquitz is doing for Al Smith is she is helping him court the women's vote. And this tells you a little bit about the time that they're in.itz is doing for Al Smith is she is helping him court the women's vote. And this tells you a little bit about the time that they're in. This is the 1918 election. This is the first time women can vote in New York State. And Bel Motsquitz, this is key advisor.
我猜我提到《敦刻尔克》好像他的其他电影都是完全线性的。这有点突兀，但我们会讲到的。所以贝尔·莫斯科维茨为阿尔·史密斯做的关键事情之一，就是帮助他争取女性选票。这告诉你一点他们所处的时代。这是1918年的选举。这是纽约州女性第一次可以投票。而贝尔·莫斯科维茨是关键顾问。
And she tells him like to win over women, you should just talk to the women the same way that you would talk to a man voter and just tell them the same things that you would tell a man. And he does and he gets their vote. And this was revolutionary. This brilliant idea that shows you really what politics was like at the time or what even American society was like at the time. So the big crusade here is reorganizing the state government. The state government is an example of, we talked about in the last episode, the sloppiness of early American governance, how kind of not organized, not put together, not governed the government was. There's this mishmash of different agencies in the state government.
她告诉他，为了赢得女性的支持，你应该像对待男性选民一样与女性交谈，只告诉她们你告诉男人的同样的事情。他照做了，并赢得了她们的选票。这具有革命性。这个绝妙的主意向你展示了当时的政治是什么样的，甚至当时的美国社会是什么样的。所以这里的大运动是重组州政府。州政府是一个例子，我们在上一集谈到了早期美国治理的草率，政府是多么的不组织、不整合、不被治理。州政府里有一堆不同的机构，
Taxes are collected by seven different agencies who will all go to the same place and demand taxes. They all report to different people in the government. It's not really clear who is responsible to anybody. The governor has no power to do much of anything. He's only in office for two years. The state doesn't even have an accurate budget. Nobody knows how much money the state spends each year.
税收由七个不同的机构征收，他们都会去同一个地方要求纳税。他们都向政府里的不同人汇报。谁对谁负责并不清楚。州长几乎没有权力做任何事情。他只任职两年。州政府甚至没有准确的预算。没有人知道州政府每年花多少钱。
It's impossible. No one knows about it. This, and I feel like we hear so much budget accounting in the news now, and it's, there's something kind of refreshing almost in the idea that back then the news was just like, money spent, we don't know, no amount's necessary, not information that we need.
这不可能。没人知道。这，我觉得我们现在在新闻里听到了太多的预算会计，而这，有一种几乎令人耳目一新的感觉，即当时的新闻只是说，钱花了，我们不知道，不需要金额，不是我们需要的信息。
I wanna bring Jamal in here a little bit to talk about this, you know, I think people's vision of politics and government is really sort of, you know, predicated on where they are, right? You know, the self-sysistic view of things worth, things are the way they're supposed to be the moment I was born and made aware of them.
我想把贾梅尔请进来谈谈这个，你知道，我认为人们对政治和政府的看法确实是基于他们所处的位置，对吧？你知道，那种自我中心的观点，认为事物在我出生并意识到它们的那一刻起就应该是这样。
But this is a very different style of politics and government than it is today. It's not very ideologically driven. It's more about what you can get and patronage and all that sort of stuff. Could you set the stage for, what does it mean to be a political reformer in the early 20th century?
但这是一种与今天完全不同的政治和政府风格。它不是意识形态驱动的。它更多是关于你能得到什么、恩庇政治以及所有这类事情。你能为我们铺垫一下，在20世纪初成为一名政治改革者意味着什么吗？
Like what are they reforming against and what kind of government are people arguing for? There are a couple ways to get at this question. And one way is to focus on one of the, I think, defining features of politics in the early 20th century, American politics in the 20th century and late 19th, which is still very regional. We live in an era right now of just completely national politics, right? Sort of almost all politics are are national one way or another. My congressman here in the Fifth District of Virginia is a guy who I'm more likely to see doing a cable news hit than I am to see around the district, right? Sort of like everything is national. But
他们反对的是什么？人们在争论什么样的政府？有几种方法可以切入这个问题。一种方法是关注我认为20世纪初美国政治的一个定义性特征，即它仍然是非常区域性的。我们现在生活在一个完全全国性政治的时代，对吧？几乎所有的政治在某种程度上都是全国性的。我在弗吉尼亚州第五选区的国会议员，我更有可能在有线电视新闻上看到他，而不是在选区里看到他，对吧？一切都是全国性的。但是
100 years ago, 120 years ago, there's no national media of that sort. Local and state party organizations were much stronger and more cohesive. They were really the main way through which people engaged in politics, which gave them a lot of sway. Today, we speak of kind of like the Democratic Party and the Republican Party as like a singular national thing with like a bunch of branches in each state. But then it's probably much more accurate to speak of the New York Democratic Party as being its own singular institution. And even within that, right?
100年前，120年前，没有那种全国性的媒体。地方和州政党组织要强大得多，也更具凝聚力。它们确实是人们参与政治的主要方式，这给了它们很大的影响力。今天，我们谈论民主党和共和党时，就像谈论一个单一的全国性事物，在每个州都有很多分支。但当时，将纽约民主党视为一个独立的单一机构可能要准确得多。即使在那个机构内部，对吧？
Sort of in the context of New York City, you have its bureau has its own Democratic club with its own, you know, set of power brokers and power brokers and everyone else. Tammany and Manhattan being kind of the most famous of them, but Brooklyn Queens, you know, the five boroughs. And the rest. Yeah. And the rest.
在纽约市的背景下，每个区都有自己的民主党俱乐部，有自己的一套权力掮客，还有其他人。坦慕尼协会和曼哈顿是其中最著名的，但布鲁克林、皇后区，你知道，五个行政区。还有其他地方。是的。还有其他地方。
So I think it's really important to kind of like understand that kind of like the organization of politics is just like way different than it is now, right? In the context of New York politics It's very organization and very machine driven machine just being kind of like a a dedicated political organization that doled out patronage rounded up votes provided, you know, like services to voters is like an important part of the important and perhaps like lost part of modern day thinking about political machines that they weren't just, it wasn't just a way to stuff a ballot box. It was also sort of like, if you had a problem with your
所以我认为理解这种政治组织与现在完全不同是非常重要的，对吧？在纽约政治的背景下，它是非常组织化和机器驱动的，“机器”只是指一种专门的政治组织，分发恩庇、拉票、为选民提供服务，这是现代人对政治机器思考中一个重要且可能被遗忘的部分，它们不仅仅是塞票箱的方式。它也是，如果你和房东有矛盾，你可以去找你的区领导说，我和房东有矛盾，党机器会试图帮你解决。因为知道这样做可能会巩固你投票给他们的承诺，并告诉你的朋友和家人，嘿，投给机器候选人。所以这种背景下的改革通常是对这些机器的改革，因为当时很多中产阶级改革者认为这很混乱和肮脏，特别是机器政治与大规模移民密切相关，对吧？这是一个来自南欧和东欧的大规模移民时期。
landlord, you could go to your war leader and be like, I have a problem with my landlord and like the party machine would try to help you out. Knowing that doing this would probably cement your commitment to giving them a vote and telling your friends and family that, hey, vote for the machine candidate. So reform in this context often is reform of like this machines because a lot of middle-class reformers around this time saw this as being kind of like messy and dirty, especially since machine politics is very much associated with like mass immigration, right? This is a period of large scale immigration from Southern and Eastern Europe.
政治机器所做的事情之一就是迅速将这些人纳入政治进程。对于许多中产阶级、新教白人改革者来说，这是一种混乱且不受欢迎的事情。所以我们在这里谈论的是纽约，但这种试图使政治进程合理化以减少混乱的类似改革精神在全国各地都在进行。其产物之一是各种形式的选举权限制。因此，秘密投票（即澳大利亚投票法）的出现就是这个过程的一部分。在南方，这是这个过程的一部分，即吉姆·克劳法。
And one of the things the political machines did was quickly incorporate these people into sort of like the political process. And for many middle class, you know, Protestant white reformers, this was sort of like messy and undesirable. So we're talking about in New York here, but this similar kind of reform spirit of trying to maybe rationalize the political process to make it less messy is going on throughout the country. And one of the products of it are various types of suffrage restriction. And so the emergence of the secret ballot called the Australian ballot is part of this process. In the South, this is part of this process is Jim Crow.
吉姆·克劳法的部分论点是，我们要通过将所有不属于这里的人排除在进程之外来清理投票。所以你是说改革有积极的一面，也有消极的一面。它并不完全是一个完全积极的努力。但那个过去的政治世界对我们来说看起来如此陌生，因为它太依赖人情了。它在微观层面上是如此的交易化，以至于看起来有点卑劣，比如，好吧，我和房东有麻烦，别担心，党会介入帮你解决。这其中有一些黑手党式的味道。但它也很有吸引力，我不知道，比如我不知道在洛杉矶的选区里，我该找政府里的谁
Part of the argument for Jim Crow is like, we're going to clean up voting by getting all of these people who don't belong out of the process. So you're saying there's a good side to reform and a bad side to reform. It is not entirely a wholly positive endeavor. But that past political world looks so alien to us because it's so favor-based. It's so transactional on a micro level in a way that seems kind of slimy where it is like, well, I'm having trouble with my landlord, don't worry, the party's going to step in and help you with that. There's something a little mafia issue about that. But it's also very, there's something appealing about that where I don't know, like I don't know who in the government
寻求帮助，比如办理许可证之类的。对，对，对。你不会。是的，我的意思是，你不会。我的意思是，也许是城市，你知道，城市里的不同人，但不是任何真正的立法者。是的。我的意思是，其中令人反感的部分是真实的。这就是为什么在芝加哥、纽约、圣路易斯、堪萨斯城，所有有强大政治机器的地方都会出现改革运动的原因，改革运动的出现正是因为所有这些都可能很快变得非常强制和腐败。与此同时，这也是我同情机器政治的地方，政府、政治与日常生活之间的那种直接联系是非常强大的，它巩固了人们的一种公民参与和公民认同感，这种认同感在今天是不存在的。这种自上而下的、高度组织的政治组织在美式政治中终结的一个后果就是，人们与政治生活失去了那种联系，因为没有中介机构来促成它。我其实觉得我也怀念这一点。我认为全国性政治有一个巨大的问题，因为没有足够的专项拨款、政治交易和所有这些事情。但现在我们说这些很容易，因为我们已经站在了它的另一面。是的。在那个时候，他们会说，我不喜欢这样。
I would turn to in my elected areas of Los Angeles for help with a permit or something like that. Right, right, right. You wouldn't. Yeah, I mean, you wouldn't. I mean, maybe the city, you know, like different people in the city, but not nobody who's like a legislator, you know, in any real way. Yeah. I mean, the unsavory parts of it are real. Like there's a reason why there pops up a reform movement in Chicago, New York, and all this in St. Louis, in Kansas City, all the places where there are powerful political machines, like a reform movement to pop up specifically because like all this can get very coercive and corrupt very quickly. At the same time, and this is sort of where my kind of sympathy for machine politics arises from, like that kind of direct connection between government and politics and everyday life is like really powerful and and and cements a sort of like level of civic participation and Civic identity and people that is like it doesn't exist these days like one consequence of the end of that kind of top-down
事实证明，当谈到政治时，草总是更绿的。但确实，理想主义和现实之间必须达成一种平衡。这就是罗伯特·摩西开始从贝尔·莫斯科维茨那里学到的东西。感谢你们为我提供了进入罗伯特·摩西故事高速公路这一部分的绝佳入口，他们有市政研究局在1915年整理的一份关于如何重组政府的报告。它没有取得任何进展，因为该局没有权力。但现在，在10年代末，贝尔·莫斯科维茨通过州长拥有了那种权力。她对摩西说，
highly organized political organization in American politics is like people don't have that kind of connection to Political life because it there's no mediating institutions to make it. I actually think I miss this too. I think there's a huge problem with national politics because there isn't enough earmarks and horse trading and all that sort of thing. It's easy for us to say that now though, because we're on the other side of it. Yeah. At that time, they were like, I don't like this.
是时候让你整理一份新报告了。告诉我们州政府应该如何构建。他会带着想法去找她，她会说，不，我们不能那样做。我知道你想取消这些职位，因为它们是多余的，但立法机关把它们用作重要的恩庇职位，我们需要这个。他们想要这个。关于公务员制度改革的这些东西，你不能放进去。那会激怒选民、工会或选民。我们不能那样做。这开始让摩西非常恼火。他们谈到当他不在贝尔的房间里时，他会经常咒骂她，他对此非常生气。但当他在她房间里时，他不会，他会守口如瓶。他不会说那些话，因为他在学习。他在学习
It turns out the grass is always greener when it comes to politics. But it's true that there's this balance between idealism and practical reality that has to be struck. And this is what Robert Moses is starting to learn from Bell Moskowitz. Thank you guys for providing me with a great on-ramp to this part of the Robert Moses story highway, where they have this report from 1915 that the Bureau of Municipal Research put together about how to reorganize the government. It didn't go anywhere because the Bureau has no power. But now, in the late teens, Bell Moskowitz has that power through the governor. And she says to Moses,
如何平衡理想主义与实际的政治关切。他在学习真正的政治权力来自哪里，以及你如何需要适应它。贝尔确实是他的老师，教他如何通过系统完成事情，真正的杠杆是什么。史密斯州长对他们说，我不想要一份只有一堆空洞想法的计划。我想要可操作的立法政策。如果你只是给我一堆想法，现在就完成报告，我会把它扔掉。那太好了，你可以直接完成你的工作了。摩西似乎把这当作了一个真正的挑战。
it's time for you to put together a new report. Tell us how the state government should be put together. And he will come to her with ideas and she will say, no, we can't do that. I know you want to eliminate these positions because they're redundant, but the legislature uses those as big patronage positions and we need that. They want that. This stuff about civil service reform, you can't put that in there. That's going to antagonize voters, workers or voters. We can't do that. And this starts to really annoy Moses. And they talk about how when he is not in the room with Bell, he swears about her a lot and he's really mad about it. But when he is in the room with her, he does not, he holds his tongue. He doesn't say those things because he's learning. And he's learning about
他非常严厉地驱使他的员工，他们也因此爱戴他。这是你从现在开始基本上看到的东西，并贯穿了摩西的整个职业生涯，那就是他可以让一群几乎总是男人，但有时也有女人的群体，为他非常非常努力地工作，通常到了最终威胁到他们自己的财务和健康的地步，因为他比任何人都努力。他有一种既多变又热情的人格，他以自己的专注和激情给员工留下了深刻印象，有时听起来像是他和员工之间的共生关系，
how you balance idealism with practical political concerns. He's learning about where actual political power comes from and how you need to accommodate it. Bell is really his teacher in how to get things done through a system, what the real levers are. And Governor Smith says to them, I don't want a plan that just has a bunch of airy ideas. I want actionable legislative policy. If you're just gonna give me a bunch of ideas, finish the report right now and I'll throw it away. That'll be great, you can just finish your job. And Moses takes this as a real challenge, it seems.
但这可能是我在进行心理分析，罗伯特·卡罗可能不会赞同我这样做。罗伯特·摩西人格的这一方面，我在整本书中从未真正搞清楚，卡罗以不同的方式谈论他，说他非常讨人喜欢，在房间里表现很好，非常努力，然后又对下属非常残忍。我不知道我是否真的能看透罗伯特·摩西，不知道经常和他待在一个房间里会是什么感觉。
He drives his staff super hard, they love him for it. And this is something that you see starting now, basically, and going throughout Moses' career is that he can get groups of almost always men, but women sometimes also, to work for him really, really hard, often to the point of threatening their own finances and health eventually, because he is working harder than everybody else. And he has a personality that is both volatile but also welcoming and impresses his employees with just how dedicated and how passionate he is in a way that at times sounds kind of like codependency between him and his
要把所有这些不同的人格特质整合到一个人类身上似乎很难。这确实是一个《公民凯恩》式的场景，是的，每个人都看到了这个大人物的一点点。但他似乎是一个能量如此惊人的形象。他有着如此压倒性的人格，以至于他带着人们一起走。我不认为这是那种他在一天中为员工做些好事的事情。
staff, but that's me psychoanalyzing probably more than Robert Carroll would approve of me doing. This aspect of Robert Moses' personality, I've never throughout the book, Carroll talks about him in different ways of him being very likable, very good in a room, talks about him in different ways of him being very likable, very good in a room, very hard driving, and then also very cruel to his subordinates. I don't know if I ever get a real bead on Robert Moses, what it would be like to be in a room with him a lot of the time.
就像，他是个硬汉，但当我需要他时，他在那里。听起来这更多只是一个对他所做的事情充满激情的人的纯粹魅力，你不得不被带走，即使事后你会想，哦，好吧，他是个刻薄的人。那太刻薄了。但在那一刻，你被卷进去了。这是我们第一次看到一个贯穿全书的事情，罗伯特·摩西精力如此充沛，以至于在深夜，他会去他家人当时租的这个海滩平房。这是1919年。他会独自在黑暗中游泳，游到比任何人都觉得安全的地方还要远，因为他精力太充沛了。他只是必须去游泳。他余生都是一个夜泳者，这感觉就像他在消耗多余的能量。这个委员会的钱用完了。摩西必须自己完成这份报告，当它完成时，卡罗确实对它充满了赞美，它非常清晰。它充满了自信，摩西几乎把全部功劳都归于自己，尽管很多人参与了其中。有一个有趣的故事，他雇佣了历史学家查尔斯·A·比尔德，他写了什么？《美国革命的经济解释》。没错。谢谢。我很高兴我把书名记对了。他雇他写了其中的一部分。然后查尔斯·比尔德拿走了他写的那部分，并将其重新用于一篇文章，摩西很生气，威胁要起诉他剽窃。比尔德简直要崩溃了。他说，但我写了这个，等一下，但我，你雇我写的。我写的。你没写。我们看到罗伯特·摩西不喜欢与人分享功劳。
It seems hard to square the circle of all these different personality traits into one human. It's a real citizen cane type scenario, yeah, where everyone sees a little bit of this big character. But it seems like he just is such an overwhelming figure of energy. He has such an overwhelming personality that he carries people along. And I don't think it's one of those things where he is kind of doing nice things for his employees throughout the day.
但他也开始在合适的人群中建立自己的名声，作为唯一能把事情做成的人。因此，在摩西的指导下，他们成立了一个“公民州政府重组委员会”。阿尔·史密斯在全州巡回演讲，他发表讲话支持报告的建议，这对摩西来说都是新鲜事，你知道，他第一次得到了支持。他也正在学习政治游戏。
Like, he's a tough guy, but he was there for me when I needed him. It sounds like it's more just the sheer charisma of somebody who is so passionate about what he's doing that you can't help but get carried along with it, even if after the fact, you're like, oh, well, he was a mean man. That was it. That was very mean of him to do that thing. But in the moment, you get swept up in it. And this is the first time we see a thing that will continue throughout the book where Robert Moses is so full of energy that at the end of the night, he will go out to this beach
他表现出了机智，就像贝尔·莫斯科维茨训练他的那样，学会尊重他人，把想法给他们。他只是在所有这些事情上更聪明。他尽最大努力不表现出明显的傲慢，也不对那些对他有直接权力的人表现出仇恨，这对他来说是新的，非常新的。他不喜欢这样。因此，在阿尔·史密斯的全力支持下，以及摩西对所有这些法律如何运作以及这些改革如何在其中运作的深刻理解，他们能够完成很多事情。
bungalow that his family is renting at the time. This is in 1919. And we'll just swim in the dark by himself and go way out farther than anyone else feels safe going because he's just so full of a energy. He just got to go swimming. And he is like a night swimmer throughout the rest of his life in a way that just feels like him burning off extra energy The money for this commission runs out. Moses has to finish this report himself and when it's finished Carol is really is really very Full of praise about it that it is very clear. It's full of confidence Moses takes almost full credit for it Even though a lot
他们设法通过了大部分改革方案。他们还没有得到州长的四年任期。他们还没有整合州官僚机构。他们还没有得到行政预算，即州长为整个州准备预算的想法。但阿尔·史密斯对罗伯特·摩西说，别担心。我会在我的下一个州长任期内做到这一点，但有一个问题。是的，任期只有两年，正如他所说，阿尔·史密斯没有连任。不，不幸的是，他的连任是在1920年的选举中，当时民主党，他的政党推举了考克斯作为总统候选人。
of people worked on it. And there's a funny story where he hires the historian Charles A. Beard who wrote, what is it? The economic interpretation of the American Revolution. That's right. Thank you. I'm so glad I got the title right. And he hires him to write part of it. And then Charles Beard takes that part of it that he wrote and repurposes it for an article and Moses gets mad and threatens to sue him for plagiarism And beard is apocalyptic. He's like, but I wrote this wait a minute, but I you hired me to write it. I wrote it. You didn't write it We're seeing that Ramos is not like to share credit with people
当然，我们的听众，我不需要提醒你们关于考克斯总统的事。我们都记得在他任期内发生的惊人事情，他和他的副总统富兰克林·罗斯福。对不起。如果你说，我不记得考克斯总统。那是因为他们没有发生。他输得很惨，也把阿尔·史密斯拖下了水。这不是富兰克林·罗斯福最后一次阻碍罗伯特·摩西，但绝对是第一次。所以那些重大的改革，它们就是没有发生。突然间，罗伯特·摩西再次不在权力领域了。对，对。委员会解散了。所有这些事情，你知道，当阿尔·史密斯不再是州长时，就消失了，除了罗伯特·摩西在纽约州协会得到了一份工作，我们会在下一章听到更多关于它的内容。
But he's also starting to build his name among the right people as the only guy who can get things done So under the guidance of Moses they formed this a citizens committee on the reorganization of state government. And Al Smith is stumping across the state and he's giving speeches and support of the reports recommendation, which is all new, like for Moses, like, you know, he is like being supported for the first time. And he's also kind of learning the political game.
但真正关键的事情之一是他已经和阿尔·史密斯成为了朋友。阿尔·史密斯确实非常欣赏罗伯特·摩西。现在他们俩都算是受人尊敬的普通公民，他们开始像朋友一样相处。是的。这里有一段我非常想读的段落，罗伯特·卡罗在描述这两个看似不匹配但出人意料地深厚结合的人物时，变得有点像查尔斯·狄更斯。这里写着。呃，在这里。这两个人走在下东区蜿蜒狭窄的街道上，在暮色中，他们是一对奇怪的组合，一个高大、苗条、英俊，举止高贵，另一个矮小、大腹便便、面色红润，高个子迈着长长的、有弹性的步伐，不得不不断缩短步幅，让那个步态缓慢、极其内八字的人赶上。他们的前进速度因为史密斯的受欢迎程度而进一步减慢。他似乎认识每一个经过的男人和女人，当其中一个人停下来聊天时，他也会停下来，毫无不耐烦地与他交谈，而他的同伴会不安地绕着小圈子走，或者试图拼命站着不动，礼貌地倾听，会紧张地握紧和松开拳头。这一章以罗伯特·摩西令人惊讶地向他认识的人报告说阿尔·史密斯听他的话而结束。是的。为了给这件事提供完整的背景，如果你要把罗伯特·摩西作为智库实习生在政治改革方面所做的一切概括起来。如果它也归结为一点，那就是像阿尔·史密斯这样的人不应该治理国家。是的。
Like he's showing tact, the sort of in the way that Bell Moskowitz has sort of trained him to kind of like defer to other people, give them his ideas. He just is smarter about all this stuff. He's trying his best not to be visibly arrogant and hateful towards the people who have immediate power over him, which is new for him, which is very new for him. He doesn't like it. And so with Alice Smith's support and with Moses's like deep knowledge of how all these laws work and how these reforms would work within them, they're able to get a lot of stuff done.
这基本上是他结束智库工作时的结论。这是他的论文。这是他的硕士论文，对吧？只有受过大学教育的人才应该担任政府职位。而阿尔·史密斯是这一点的对立面，正如我们进入第七章所看到的那样。但是的，这是我想在进入阿尔·史密斯惊人地崛起为纽约政治巅峰之前，听听你们想法的事情，那就是阿尔·史密斯对外人来说，他是一个坦慕尼协会的人。他是那种机器政治的象征。正如你所说，罗曼·摩西的改革理论上都是关于，我们不应该让那样的人掌权。只有受过大学教育的人才应该。民主的、干净的做事方式是不应该有这种机器腐败。但只有在那种机器腐败的世界里，一个像阿尔·史密斯这样出身底层的人才能崛起。这个想法，哪一个才是真正更民主的制度？因为如果摩西如愿以偿，就像你说的，你不会在政府里看到阿尔·史密斯。但只有阿尔·史密斯能够完成摩西试图做的那些改革，而且，我想这可能与你之前说的改革运动也是关于清除某些类型的选民或某些类型的民众成员有关。这是什么，我没有办法把它表述为一个问题，但你能谈谈吗？我想那是一个问题。是的，当然。我的意思是，这是美国政治在这一时期的宏观图景，它是非常分裂的，对吧？所以，在19世纪80年代和90年代，你有农民联盟和民粹党，这非常具有破坏性。我的意思是，我认为今天，在任何了解民粹主义者的程度上，是的，农民生气了，他们有一个政党，并参加了一些选举，
They manage to pass a lot of this reform package. They don't get the biggest things. They don't get the four-year term for the governor yet. They don't get to consolidate the state bureaucracy yet. They don't get the executive budget, the idea that the governor would prepare a budget for the whole state. But Al Smith says to Robert Moses, don't worry. I'm gonna do that in my next term as governor but There's a problem Yeah, the the term is only two years as he said and Al Smith does not get reelected No, unfortunately his reelection is during the election of 1920 when when the Democrats, his party put up as President Cox.
但民粹党在鼎盛时期，或多或少地动摇了全国的美国政治。所以你有劳工动荡，全国各地都有非常严重和暴力的劳工动荡。发生了多重经济危机。1893年有恐慌。20世纪初可能有一点衰退。所以这是进步改革时代的背景，这就是这一切的一部分。进步主义在两个党派中都作为一种改革运动存在。有共和党进步主义者，也有民主党进步主义者。
And of course, our audience, I don't have to remind you about President Cox. We all remember the amazing things that happened under his term, his tenure, him and his vice president, Franklin Roosevelt. I'm sorry. If you're like, I don't remember President Cox. It's because they didn't happen. He lost really badly and took Al Smith down with him. Not the last time
当然，对于我们的听众，我不需要提醒你们关于考克斯总统的事。我们都记得在他任期内发生的那些惊人的事情，他和他当时的副总统富兰克林·罗斯福。抱歉，如果你在想，我不记得有考克斯总统。那是因为这些事根本没发生过。他输得很惨，还连累了阿尔·史密斯。这并不是最后一次
that Franklin Roosevelt will get in the way of Robert Moses, but certainly the first time. And so those major reforms, they just don't happen. And suddenly, once again, Robert Moses is not in the realm of power anymore. Right, right. The committee gets disbanded. All that stuff, you know, just sort of goes away when Al Smith is no longer the governor, except that Robert Moses takes this job at the New York State Association, which is something we'll hear a little bit more about the next chapter.
富兰克林·罗斯福阻碍罗伯特·摩西，但这绝对是第一次。所以那些重大的改革根本没有实现。突然间，罗伯特·摩西再次失去了权力。没错，没错。委员会解散了。当阿尔·史密斯不再担任州长时，所有这些事情就随之烟消云散了，除了罗伯特·摩西在纽约州协会谋得了一个职位，我们将在下一章中详细了解这一点。
But one of the real key things is he has become friends with Al Smith. Like Al Smith has really taken a shine to Robert Moses. And now that they're both sort of like, esteemed private citizens, they begin both sort of like, you know, esteemed private citizens, they begin to hang out like his friends. Yes. There's a passage that I'd love to read here where Robert Carroll becomes kind of Charles Dickensie in describing these two seemingly mismatched but surprisingly deeply
但其中一个关键点是，他已经和阿尔·史密斯成为了朋友。阿尔·史密斯真的很欣赏罗伯特·摩西。现在他们俩都算是受人尊敬的普通公民，他们开始像朋友一样相处。是的。这里有一段我很想读的文字，罗伯特·卡罗在描述这两个看似不般配但却出人意料地深厚
bonded figures. This is where it says it here. Uh, here it is. The two men made an odd pair as they walked through the winding, narrow streets of the Lower East Side and the Twilight, one of them tall, slim, handsome, and aristocratic and bearing, the other short, pot-bellied florid, the taller man striding out with long springing steps continually had to shorten his stride to let the other, who walked with a slow, extremely pigeon-toed gate catch up. Their progress was further slowed by Smith's popularity. He seemed to know almost every man and woman who passed, and when one of them stopped to
结下情谊的人物时，变得非常有查尔斯·狄更斯的风格。就是这里写的。嗯，找到了。这两个人走在下东区蜿蜒狭窄的街道上，在暮色中显得格格不入，一个高大、苗条、英俊，举止优雅，另一个矮小、大腹便便、面色红润。高个子迈着长而轻快的步伐，不得不不断缩短步幅，好让那个走路缓慢、内八字步态极其明显的人跟上。他们的行进速度因为史密斯的受欢迎程度而进一步放慢。他似乎认识每一个经过的男人和女人，当其中一人停下来
chat he would stop too, and talk with him without appearance of impatience, while his companion would stride restlessly in little circles, or, trying desperately to stand still and listen politely, would nervously clench and unclench his fists. And the chapter ends with Robert Moses amazingly reporting to the people he knows that Al Smith listens to him. Yeah. And just to give full context of this, if you were to sort of encapsulate all of what Robert Moses did as this intern of a think tank when it comes to political reform. If it also came down to like one point, it is people like Al Smith shouldn't govern. Yes.
聊天时，他也会停下来，毫无不耐烦地与对方交谈，而他的同伴则会焦躁不安地绕着小圈走，或者试图拼命站住并礼貌地倾听，紧张地握紧又松开拳头。这一章的结尾是罗伯特·摩西令人惊讶地向他认识的人报告说，阿尔·史密斯听他的话。是的。为了提供完整的背景，如果你要把罗伯特·摩西作为智库实习生在政治改革方面所做的一切概括起来，如果归结为一点，那就是像阿尔·史密斯这样的人不应该执政。是的。
That is basically his conclusion at the end of his time at the think tank. This is his thesis. This is his master's thesis, right? Is that only people with college This is his master's thesis, right? Is that only people with college educations should be in government positions. And Al Smith is the antithesis of that as we get through, go into chapter seven. But yeah, this is something that I wanted to get
这基本上是他结束智库工作时的结论。这就是他的论文。这是他的硕士论文，对吧？即只有受过大学教育的人才应该担任政府职务。而阿尔·史密斯正是这一观点的对立面，正如我们进入第七章所看到的那样。但是的，这是我想在进入阿尔·史密斯在纽约政坛惊人崛起之前，
your guys thought on before we get into Al Smith's amazing rise to the height of New York politics, is that Al Smith to the outsider, he's a Tammany man. He's kind of emblematic of that kind of machine politics. And as you're saying, Roman Moses reforms in theory are all about, we shouldn't have guys like that in power. Only the college educated should. That the democratic clean way of doing things is to not have this kind of machine corruption. But it's only in the world of that machine corruption that a guy as
听听你们想法的地方，那就是对于局外人来说，阿尔·史密斯是一个坦慕尼协会的人。他是那种机器政治的象征。正如你所说，罗伯特·摩西的改革理论核心是，我们不应该让那样的人掌权。只有受过大学教育的人才应该掌权。民主且清廉的做事方式是不应该有这种机器腐败。但只有在那种机器腐败的世界里，一个像
From the bottom as Al Smith can rise to the top this idea that Which is the truly more democratic system because if Moses has his way like you're saying you wouldn't see an alismis in government But it is only al Smith who was able to get through the kinds of reforms that Moses is trying to do and you know, I guess this this maybe dovetails with what you were saying earlier about Reform movements also being about removing certain types of voters or certain types of members of the populace. What is the, is that, I don't have a way to phrase it as a question, but can you talk about it? I guess that's a question. Yeah, sure. I mean, this is the, um, the macro picture of like American politics in kind of this period
阿尔·史密斯这样出身底层的人才能崛起。这种想法，究竟哪一个才是真正更民主的制度？因为如果按照摩西的方式，正如你所说，你不会在政府中看到像阿尔·史密斯这样的人。但正是阿尔·史密斯能够推动摩西试图进行的那些改革，而且，我想这可能与你之前提到的关于改革运动也是为了清除某些类型的选民或某些类型的民众成员的观点相吻合。这是什么，我不知道怎么把它表述为一个问题，但你能谈谈吗？我想这是一个问题。是的，当然。我的意思是，这是美国政治在这一时期的宏观图景，
of like American politics in kind of this period is that it's really fractitious, right? So in the 1880s and 1890s, you have the Farmers Alliance and the Populus Party, which is like hugely disruptive. I mean, I think today, to the extent that anyone learns about the populace, so yeah, the farmers got angry and they had a party and it contested some elections,
即它非常分裂，对吧？所以在19世纪80年代和90年代，你有农民联盟和人民党，这具有巨大的破坏性。我的意思是，我认为今天，就人们对民粹主义的了解程度而言，是的，农民们愤怒了，他们成立了一个政党并参加了一些选举，
but like the Populus Party at its height, more or less unsettled American politics across the country. And so you have this, you have labor unrest, like really serious and violent labor unrest throughout the country. There's multiple economic crises happening. There's a panic in 1893. There's maybe a little recession in the beginning 20th century So kind of a context for the progressive reform era Which is what this is all kind of a part of like progressivism Exists in both parties as a reform movement. They're Republican progressives. They're Democratic progressives
但在鼎盛时期，人民党或多或少地动摇了全国的美国政治。所以你有劳工动荡，全国范围内非常严重且暴力的劳工动荡。发生了多重经济危机。1893年有一次恐慌。20世纪初可能还有一次小衰退。所以这为进步改革时代提供了一个背景，而这正是这一切的一部分，比如进步主义在两个党派中都作为一种改革运动存在。有共和党进步派，也有民主党进步派。
They exist within, you know, the Tammany machine has people who would identify as progressives. And this is, I think to a large extent, like Robert Moses, and it's a group of people who are in that know you, a guy who I'm sure will get mentioned in the book, Robert F. Wagner, because he's sort of like a very important figure in national politics in the 1930s. We'll hear about Robert Wagner and we'll hear about his son, the other Robert Wagner. Yes. Not the actor. Yeah. If you're ever, if you're googling this, you gotta remember there's an actor named Robert Wagner too. So you want to look for Robert F. Wagner is the politician. His son is also Robert
它们存在于，你知道，坦慕尼协会（Tammany machine）里也有人会自认为是进步派。我认为在很大程度上，这就像罗伯特·摩西（Robert Moses）一样，这是一群知情的人，有一个我肯定会在书中提到的人，罗伯特·F·瓦格纳（Robert F. Wagner），因为他在20世纪30年代的全国政治中是一个非常重要的人物。我们会听到关于罗伯特·瓦格纳的事，也会听到他儿子，另一个罗伯特·瓦格纳的事。是的。不是那个演员。是的。如果你在谷歌上搜索这个，你得记住还有一个叫罗伯特·瓦格纳的演员。所以你要找的是政治家罗伯特·F·瓦格纳。他的儿子也是罗伯特
Wagner, Jr. And then there's Robert Wagner from heart to heart. Yeah. No, but it's the fractiousness and in some cases, the violence of American politics that like a lot of performers want to get a handle on. It's the very real corruption. All of this is also happening. I mentioned there's mass immigration during all of this. What's also happening is sort of like a growing kind of like nativistic attitude within American politics. The progressive reformers, whether they're operating in New York or other northern and
瓦格纳二世。然后还有《心连心》（Hart to Hart）里的罗伯特·瓦格纳。是的。不，但正是美国政治中的派系斗争，在某些情况下甚至是暴力，是许多表演者想要掌控的东西。这是非常真实的腐败。所有这些也都在发生。我提到过在此期间有大规模移民。同时发生的还有一种在美国政治中日益增长的本土主义态度。进步派改革者，无论他们是在纽约还是其他北部和
middle-northic cities, whether they're out west in California, whether they've been down south, the progressive reformers are trying to do like a bunch of things and one of them is this attempt to rationalize politics, reduce the level of frictitiousness and like violence and conflict, promote people who are interested in scientific, quote-unquote scientific government, government by experts, government by people with a base of knowledge. And this is like the ugly side.
中北部城市，无论他们是在西部的加利福尼亚，还是在南部，进步派改革者都在试图做很多事情，其中之一就是试图使政治合理化，减少派系斗争、暴力和冲突的程度，提拔那些对所谓的“科学”政府、专家治国、由拥有知识基础的人来治理感兴趣的人。这就是丑陋的一面。
It's like the more ordinary immigrant voters, laboring voters, like what do they know? What do they know about the ministry and the government? Maybe they shouldn't have as much of a say. Maybe we should be finding ways to have them be less of a part of the political process. And to be clear, you're saying what they would be thinking. We shouldn't take that out of context
就像那些更普通的移民选民、劳工选民，他们懂什么？他们对政府和行政了解多少？也许他们不应该有那么大的发言权。也许我们应该想办法让他们少参与政治进程。需要明确的是，你是在说他们会怎么想。我们不应该断章取义
and put it into a political act. New York Times columnist, Jamel Bowie, does not think immigrants should be involved. Oh, I'm so glad that we settled that. Oh, thank goodness. But I think what I was thinking in that moment was actually like, how overt was the anti-immigrant sort of bigoted nature of this reform movement? Was it all subtext or did they talk about it openly?
并将其转化为政治行为。《纽约时报》专栏作家贾梅尔·布伊（Jamel Bouie）并不认为移民应该参与其中。哦，我很高兴我们解决了这个问题。哦，谢天谢地。但我当时想的其实是，这种改革运动中反移民的偏执本质有多明显？这全是潜台词，还是他们公开谈论过？
Well, it wasn't subtext at all. Was it supertext? Let me pull up something real quick. There's a wonderful book from the 1970s by a political scientist still living in J. Morgan Cooser called The Shaping of Southern Politics Suffrage
嗯，这根本不是潜台词。这是显性文本吗？让我快速调出一些东西。有一本70年代由一位至今仍在世的政治学家J·摩根·库瑟（J. Morgan Kousser）写的精彩著作，叫《南方政治的塑造：选举权》
Restriction and the Establishment of the Bloom Party South. And it's mostly about right the South, but it deals because it takes place during this time, it deals with similar kinds of movements happening throughout the country. Here we go. This is from the book.
《限制与“固态南方”的建立》（The Shaping of Southern Politics: Suffrage Restriction and the Establishment of the One-Party South）。它主要讲的是南方，但因为它发生在这个时期，它也涉及全国各地发生的类似运动。好了，就是这个。这是书中的内容。
Between 1889 and 1913, nine states outside the South made the ability to read English, a qualification for voting. In Rhode Island required voters to pay at least $1 in taxes. Writing in the prestigious North American Review, a prominent University of Michigan geologist denounced, quote, the communist principle of universal and equal suffrage, quote, it is not an injustice to those who surrender control.
在1889年到1913年间，南方以外的九个州将阅读英语的能力作为投票的资格。罗德岛要求选民至少缴纳1美元的税款。一位著名的密歇根大学地质学家在权威的《北美评论》（North American Review）上撰文，谴责所谓的“普遍和平等选举权的共产主义原则”，称“对于那些放弃控制权的人来说，这并非不公正。”
It is justice to those who have the right to the best government. It is justice to those whom nature and education have fitted to administer best government. This is not oppression of the masses by a selected few. It is the best protection of the masses from all political evils, the best guidance of the masses towards the blessings of higher national and individual prosperity. Other northerners supported state or national literacy tests to reduce the influence of immigrants or Negroes or expelled the quote, bosses and quote, demagogues who allegedly benefited from the votes of these groups. That's generally the tenor of conversation.
“对于那些有权获得最好政府的人来说，这是公正的。对于那些天性和教育使其适合管理最好政府的人来说，这是公正的。这不是少数精英对大众的压迫。这是对大众免受一切政治邪恶的最好保护，是引导大众走向更高国家和个人繁荣福祉的最好指南。”其他北方人支持州或全国性的识字测试，以减少移民或黑人的影响，或驱逐那些据称从这些群体选票中获益的所谓“老板”和“煽动者”。这通常就是当时谈话的基调。
So let's take a quick break and when we come back, we're going to get to one of our favorite sessions of the book, a little micro biography of Al Smith, the great Al Smith after this. So this is part of the book where we talk about Al Smith. And right here, Carol jumps back in time. And you're not paying close attention. It is pretty confusing for many of us. Because you're suddenly like, wait, he's a child now. I thought he was the governor. I thought he was the governor.
那么让我们休息一下，回来后，我们将进入书中我们最喜欢的部分之一，关于伟大的阿尔·史密斯（Al Smith）的小传，休息之后见。所以这是书中我们谈论阿尔·史密斯的部分。就在这里，卡罗（Caro）跳回了过去。如果你不仔细看，对我们许多人来说这确实很令人困惑。因为你突然会觉得，等等，他现在是个孩子了。我以为他是州长。我以为他是州长。
And then he was the governor, not elected in 1918. And then he goes back and... All my life, I wanted to be the governor and then be faced to... Yeah. That'll be the movie version of it. So we're in chapter seven now, which is called Change of Major. And it opens with a long section that I will try to do quickly and not do detailed. I love it. This is a 17-page section. It's half the chapter, which is just telling the
然后他确实是州长，1918年没选上。然后他又回到了……我一生都想成为州长，然后面对……是的。那将是电影版的情节。所以我们现在在第七章，叫“专业变更”（Change of Major）。它以一个很长的部分开头，我会尽量快速讲完，不讲细节。我喜欢这个。这是一个17页的部分。它占了整章的一半，只是在讲述
life story of Al Smith. And every time I think about this book, I know it's 17 pages. It stuck from the first time I read it. And I'll be like, there's no way that section 17 pages. I must be exaggerating. And then I'll go back and read through it again. I'm like, no, it is. They talk about Al Smith for a long time to the point where when Robert Moses comes back in, I remember the first time I read this book, I was really enjoying Al Smith's life. And then it Robert Moses came back and I was like, Oh, yeah, this book is about Robert Moses. Like, it felt like two superheroes were finally teaming
阿尔·史密斯的人生故事。每次我想到这本书，我知道它是17页。我第一次读它时就记住了。我会想，那部分不可能有17页。我一定是在夸大其词。然后我会回去再读一遍。我想，不，确实是。他们谈论阿尔·史密斯谈了很久，以至于当罗伯特·摩西再次出现时，我记得我第一次读这本书时，我真的很享受阿尔·史密斯的生活。然后罗伯特·摩西回来了，我就想，哦，对了，这本书是关于罗伯特·摩西的。就像两个超级英雄终于联手了
up that I had been reading their books, you know, separately for a long time. But he is the exact opposite in many ways of Moses upbringing. And Caro compares them specifically. He says, at this age that Moses is doing this, Al Smith is doing this. He's growing up in the Irish Tenements of New York's fourth ward, right at the foot of the Brooklyn Bridge. It's all tenements.
我读他们的书已经很久了，你知道，是分开读的。但在许多方面，他与摩西的成长背景完全相反。卡罗专门对他们进行了比较。他说，在摩西做这件事的这个年纪，阿尔·史密斯正在做那件事。他在纽约第四区的爱尔兰贫民窟长大，就在布鲁克林大桥脚下。全是贫民窟。
It's kind of your classic, easy to romanticize, but actually very terrible to live in tenements. And his father dies when he's young. His mother is literally worried that if she cannot financially support her children, they'll be taken away from her and put in an institution. And finally, he drops out of school at 13 and goes to work. For much of the time he's working at Fulton Fish Market,
这是一种经典的、容易被浪漫化，但实际上居住环境非常糟糕的贫民窟。他父亲在他很小的时候就去世了。他母亲真的担心如果她不能在经济上供养她的孩子，他们会被带走并关进收容所。最后，他在13岁时辍学去工作。大部分时间他在富尔顿鱼市场（Fulton Fish Market）工作，
where Carol notes he works from 4 a.m. to 5 p.m. every day, except Friday, when he starts work at 3 a.m. It's not that he has Friday off, it's just he has one extra hour of work. But he also starts getting into the kind of low-level political work that Jamel you were telling us about, which they describe as executing contracts, which is kind of favors, you know, that they talk about like tipping off a brothel owner that there's going to be a raid, so maybe get ready for it. Or there's a poor constituent who needs a little bit of help because they lost their job. And each of these things is a favor that you're doing. And they know that
卡罗指出他每天从凌晨4点工作到下午5点，周五除外，那天他从凌晨3点开始工作。并不是说他周五休息，只是他多工作了一个小时。但他同时也开始从事贾梅尔你告诉我们的那种低级政治工作，他们将其描述为“执行合同”，这其实就是人情往来，你知道，他们谈论的是比如给妓院老板通风报信说要突击检查，所以最好准备一下。或者有一个贫困的选民因为失业需要一点帮助。而每一件事都是你做的一个人情。他们知道
the person you're doing the favor knows this is the Democratic Party who's doing this, me this favor. And specifically, the local Democratic ward boss, who in this case is a guy named Big Tom Foley, which is a great, if you want to be a machine politician, you should have big in the front of your name. That should be your nickname. It can only sound kind of corrupt. It never sounds like... It's hard to imagine a politician with big at the front of his name who is above board and just known for his honesty, like big Abe Lincoln or something like that. And he catches big time fully his eye because Al Smith is someone everyone seems to like. He goes out of his way to do as much as he can for people. He works hard.
你做人情的那个人知道这是民主党在做这件事，在帮我这个忙。具体来说，是当地的民主党区老板，在这个案例中是一个叫“大汤姆”·福利（Big Tom Foley）的人，这是一个很棒的名字，如果你想成为一名机器政治家，你的名字前面应该加个“大”字。那应该是你的绰号。它听起来只能是有点腐败。它从来听起来不像……很难想象一个名字前面有“大”字的政治家是光明正大、以诚实著称的，比如“大亚伯”·林肯之类的。他引起了“大汤姆”·福利的注意，因为阿尔·史密斯似乎是每个人都喜欢的人。他竭尽全力为人们做尽可能多的事。他工作努力。
People just seem to like him. And he says, hey, I'm going to put you up as a state assemblyman. And Al Smith is like, oh, okay, sure. Yeah, that would be great. And he gets elected. He goes to the state legislature in Albany and he finds it impenetrable. The speeches are impenetrable. The wording of the bills is impenetrable.
人们似乎就是喜欢他。他说，嘿，我要推举你做州议员。阿尔·史密斯就说，哦，好的，没问题。是的，那太棒了。他当选了。他去了奥尔巴尼的州议会，发现那里深不可测。演讲是深不可测的。法案的措辞是深不可测的。
Again, this is a guy who dropped out of school at 13. And this is a New York school in the late 19th century. This is not an amazing school, probably. And each night, after kind of carousing with his fellow legislators, because a lot of the job of being in the state legislature seems to be to go drinking with the other legislators, he'd go back to the room he was staying in and read through every single bill that was brought up that day and the older bills they referred to. And it's his way of just trying to figure out what do these things mean? Like, what do they mean? Why are they written this way? What are the people who introduced this bill? What are they thinking? Why are they thinking this way? It has to be done. And he needs money. He has a family by this point. And he goes to big Tom Foley and Tom Foley says, I'll give you this big patronage job, this plum job, it's not a lot of work, it's good money.
再说一次，这是一个13岁就辍学的人。而且这是19世纪末的纽约学校。这可能不是什么好学校。每天晚上，在和他的议员同事们狂欢之后，因为在州议会工作的大部分内容似乎就是和其他议员一起喝酒，他会回到他住的房间，读完那天提出的每一项法案以及它们所引用的旧法案。这是他试图弄清楚这些东西意味着什么的方式？比如，它们是什么意思？为什么它们要这样写？提出这项法案的人是谁？他们在想什么？他们为什么要这样想？这必须得做。而且他需要钱。此时他已经有了家庭。他去找“大汤姆”·福利，汤姆·福利说，我会给你这个重要的赞助工作，这个肥差，工作不多，钱很多。
But if you take it, you'll never be a big man in New York. But hey, maybe Albany's too tough for you. You know, maybe you're just not ready for it. And Smith decides to turn down that job and he goes back to Albany. And while he's a state legislator, he is entirely a Tammany man. Whatever Big Tom Foley tells him to do, he does it. And he spends his days voting whatever his order to vote,
但如果你接受了，你就永远成不了纽约的大人物。但是嘿，也许奥尔巴尼对你来说太难了。你知道，也许你还没准备好。史密斯决定拒绝那份工作，他回到了奥尔巴尼。当他担任州议员时，他完全是坦慕尼的人。无论“大汤姆”·福利让他做什么，他都照做。他每天花时间投票，无论被命令投什么票，
winning over his colleagues with kind of jokes and things. But then at night, when nobody knows what he's doing, he's just researching and reading and studying and researching and learning. And as we know, there's nothing Robert Caro admires more than deep research that involves reading papers long into the night. But any time a character does interviews or researching papers in this book, they are it instantly there's a shine that glows for them. And we'll talk about this more later actually, but because it will get into the into the
用笑话之类的方式赢得同事的好感。但在晚上，当没人知道他在做什么时，他只是在研究、阅读、学习和研究。正如我们所知，罗伯特·卡罗最钦佩的就是涉及深夜阅读文件的深入研究。但在这本书中，每当一个角色进行采访或研究文件时，他们身上立刻就会散发出一种光芒。我们稍后会更多地谈论这一点，因为我们会进入
deeper weeds of Bill writing. But I as it as a dilettante when it comes to politics, in our read about it, but I'm not a New York Times columnist or anything like that. Jamal, can you enlighten us why are laws written so complicatedly? Why are they so complicated? Why do we need a whole court whose job seems to be just to tell us what words that are in the dictionary, like what they mean? Why should he have to study so hard to understand what these laws are saying? are in the dictionary, like what they mean. Why should he have to study so hard to understand what these laws are saying?
法案起草的更深处。但我作为一个政治上的业余爱好者，虽然读过相关内容，但我不是《纽约时报》的专栏作家之类的。贾梅尔，你能启发我们一下吗，为什么法律写得这么复杂？为什么它们如此复杂？为什么我们需要一个整个法院，其工作似乎只是告诉我们字典里的词是什么意思？他为什么要那么努力地学习才能理解这些法律在说什么？
A lot of reasons. So first, a piece of legislation may effectively just be an amendment of an older piece of legislation. So you need to know the language of the older piece of legislation. A, to understand what this new one is doing, and B, to even write it.
原因很多。首先，一项立法可能实际上只是对旧立法的一项修正案。所以你需要了解旧立法的语言。A，为了理解这项新法律在做什么，B，甚至为了起草它。
You have to have knowledge of this previous piece of legislation. And then these things are written in like a kind of very technical legalistic language. And that explains 90% of it. And so where a court comes in is, first of all, I mean, most often, the bill is written. It's passed into law. It's being implemented.
你必须具备对之前这项立法的了解。然后这些东西是用一种非常技术性的法律语言写成的。这解释了90%的原因。所以法院介入的地方是，首先，我的意思是，最常见的情况是，法案被起草了。它被通过成为法律。它正在被实施。
And the people tasked with implementing it, they're reading it. They're cross-checking it based on what they know, and they begin to take action. Then someone else, maybe, is affected by their actions, is, hey, I don't think you're reading that correctly. This is what I think this means, that the law says. And now, the legislature doesn't really... It's doing other stuff now. It's not going to go back and clarify. So the job of the court is they look at the text, they look at the legislative history,
而负责实施它的人，他们正在阅读它。他们根据自己所知道的进行交叉核对，然后开始采取行动。然后其他人，也许是受他们行动影响的人，会说，嘿，我不认为你读得对。这就是我认为法律所说的意思。现在，立法机关并不真的……它现在在做其他事情。它不会回去澄清。所以法院的工作是他们查看文本，查看立法历史，
they look at, you know, similar laws, maybe, and how those are implemented, how they look at everything and they say, well, we think that this understanding of the law makes the most sense. And that's kind of most of the deal, right? Just sort of law writing is a technical process. It's an interpretive process. And the people who write laws are often trying to do it in such a way as to make sure that what they want to happen actually happens. This is sort of like. You gotta write it in a way that we want x to happen specifically, and you need to make sure that it does actually happen. Because there's someone else who can come along and say, oh, but that law kind of says y. I know maybe you wanted x, but
他们查看，你知道，类似的法律，也许，以及它们是如何实施的，他们查看一切，然后说，嗯，我们认为这种对法律的理解最有意义。这基本上就是大部分情况，对吧？法律起草是一种技术过程。这是一个解释过程。而起草法律的人通常试图以一种确保他们想要发生的事情确实发生的方式来做。这有点像。你必须以一种我们想要X具体发生的方式来写它，你需要确保它确实发生了。因为会有其他人走过来说，哦，但那条法律说的是Y。我知道也许你想要X，但
y works also. Is that right? Yeah. You wanted x, but what you wrote is more akin to Y. You're doing X, but you can't do X because actually it means what? You want to avoid that situation as much as possible. Well, now that I know how complicated it is, it is less surprising to me that it takes Al Smith until his fifth term in the state legislature to finally understand how laws work and what's going on. This is a bit of my own little listeners. know, listeners, this is my own hobby for us. So if you disagree with me, whatever, just ignore it.
Y也行得通。是这样吗？是的。你想要X，但你写的东西更接近Y。你在做X，但你不能做X，因为实际上它的意思是别的？你想要尽可能避免这种情况。好吧，既然我知道它有多复杂，我就不那么惊讶阿尔·史密斯直到他的第五个任期才最终理解法律是如何运作的以及发生了什么。这是我自己的小听众。你知道，听众们，这是我自己的爱好。所以如果你不同意我，随便吧，忽略它。
Like, you know, fast forward through. But this is actually the basic problem with like term limits as a concept that like when you get elected to a legislature, your first term, 90% of it is learning who the people are, what the basic rules are, and that's it. And if you get elected to a second term, then you can learn a little more. And in practice, especially for when the terms are two years or three years, in practice, your first five terms might simply be equivalent to orientation.
就像，你知道，快进跳过。但这实际上是任期限制作为一个概念的基本问题，即当你当选进入立法机关时，你的第一个任期，90%的时间是在学习谁是谁，基本规则是什么，仅此而已。如果你当选第二个任期，那么你可以多学一点。而在实践中，特别是当任期为两年或三年时，在实践中，你的前五个任期可能仅仅相当于入职培训。
Sort of like, okay, I've been here for 10 years. Now I know enough to do something that I want to do. And a term limit basically like short circuits that process, but the term limit does is say, okay, you're now at the point where you have enough knowledge and you have you built enough relationships and you've developed an area of expertise or an area of interest, you're at the point where you can write a law and build a coalition and get it passed. Well, now you can't be in a legislative training more.
有点像，好吧，我在这里待了10年了。现在我知道得足够多了，可以做一些我想做的事情了。而任期限制基本上就像是短路了这个过程，但任期限制所做的是说，好吧，你现在到了一个拥有足够知识、建立了足够关系、发展出了专业领域或兴趣领域的点，你到了可以起草法律、建立联盟并使其通过的点。好吧，现在你不能再在立法机构待了。
Goodbye, you can't be here. Yeah. But even a term limit, like a single term being so short is an impediment to all of this. And it's pretty fascinating. I think one thing you have to sort of think about that's different today as back then is like, essentially campaigns are so long that two years
再见，你不能待在这里了。是的。但即使是任期限制，比如单一任期如此之短，也是所有这些的障碍。这非常迷人。我认为有一件事你必须考虑，即今天与过去的不同之处在于，本质上竞选活动太长了，以至于两年
that you're basically, you get elected, you have to basically, you're focused on being reelected. It's like immediate. Whereas I think these campaigns, when he talks about different campaigns later on, they're like a month long maybe, on the outside. They're pretty short. And especially when, you know, like on the outside. Pretty sure.
你基本上，你当选了，你基本上必须，你专注于再次当选。这就像是即时的。而我认为这些竞选活动，当他后来谈到不同的竞选活动时，它们可能长达一个月，最多。它们相当短。尤其是当，你知道，比如最多。相当确定。
Especially when you're running for the state legislature and you got big Tom Foley in your corner, you're not really campaigning too hard. Yeah, you're kind of just... You got the bully boys standing on beer barrels, giving speeches on street corners and that's enough and, you know, everyone knows favors and... Guys with bats, you know, that kind of thing. Oh, yeah, of course. Oh, the good old days. Yeah. Yeah, of course. In by 1911, he is the majority leader for his party. He's still doing Tammany business. There's a kind of a little bit of a turning moment as a result of the Triangle Shirt Waste Factory Fire,
尤其是当你竞选州议员并且有“大汤姆”·福利在背后支持你时，你并没有真正太努力地竞选。是的，你基本上只是……你有那些站在啤酒桶上在街角发表演讲的打手，这就足够了，而且，你知道，每个人都知道人情往来，还有……拿着棒球棍的家伙，你知道，那种事。哦，是的，当然。哦，美好的旧时光。是的。是的，当然。到1911年，他是他所在政党的多数党领袖。他仍然在做坦慕尼的生意。由于三角内衣工厂火灾（Triangle Shirtwaist Factory Fire），出现了一个小小的转折点，
one of the one of the great labor tragedies in the United States history. And he adds himself to the committee that's investigating it for the state. And he starts to make relationships with the reformers were also working on that committee and working in the cause of safer labor situations, especially for New York garment workers, but for workers in general. And he starts to make this relationship with a few reformers who see that he's uneducated. He seems to have no political ideology, really whatsoever, but he cares in a broader sense of the idea of taking care of the people, of little people. He is what Jamel, you were saying about him about populism.
这是美国历史上最伟大的劳工悲剧之一。他把自己加入到为州调查此事的委员会中。他开始与也在该委员会工作并为更安全的劳动环境而努力的改革者建立关系，特别是为纽约服装工人，但也为广大工人。他开始与几位改革者建立这种关系，他们看出他受教育程度不高。他似乎根本没有任何政治意识形态，但他关心照顾人民、小人物的更广泛意义上的想法。他就是贾梅尔你所说的关于他的民粹主义。
He is that kind of populist in the positive sense of the word, you know, and he becomes a very powerful speaker for the rights of workers and the rights of the poor while he's still at the same time doing Tammany business and he becomes the assembly speaker, He gets a reputation for working efficiently. He bullies laws through and he might stand up for a progressive bill. But if Tammany says, don't do this, he will switch on a dime. So that 1915 reorganization report that failed, the one before Moses' report, he was in support of it. And then his boss is like, don't do this. And he says to them, sorry, boys, got the word, can't do it. Like he's very open about how he was told he can't vote, support it. So
他是那种积极意义上的民粹主义者，你知道，他成为了工人权利和穷人权利的非常有力的发言人，同时他仍然在做坦慕尼的生意，他成为了议会议长，他以工作高效而闻名。他强行通过法律，他可能会支持一项进步法案。但如果坦慕尼说，别这么做，他会立刻改变立场。所以那份失败的1915年重组报告，在摩西的报告之前的那份，他曾支持它。然后他的老板说，别这么做。他对他们说，抱歉，伙计们，接到命令了，不能做。就像他非常公开地表示他被告知不能投票支持它。所以
he's not supporting it. But behind the scenes, he's starting to kind of lobby the Tammany people to change their thinking a little bit. And he's getting traction because they have a goal they think he might be able to achieve, which is to be the first Irish American governor of the state. It's something they've never been able to establish. And it means a lot to this very Irish political machine in a city with a lot of Irish voters who are looked down on. And so in 1918, as we know, she's elected governor. He's associated in that campaign. And then for the rest of his life, with the then new song, the sidewalks of New York, a song that I feel like I only know from old cartoons and things like that. That's the one that goes east, side, west, side, all around the town. In London, bridges falling down To poison girls together
他不支持它。但在幕后，他开始游说坦慕尼的人稍微改变他们的想法。他正在获得支持，因为他们有一个他们认为他可能能够实现的目标，那就是成为该州第一位爱尔兰裔美国州长。这是他们从未能够确立的事情。对于这个在有很多爱尔兰选民且被看不起的城市里的非常爱尔兰化的政治机器来说，这意味着很多。所以1918年，正如我们所知，他当选州长。他在那次竞选中与当时的新歌《纽约的人行道》（The Sidewalks of New York）联系在一起，这首歌我觉得我只在旧动画片之类的地方听过。就是那首唱着“东边，西边，全城到处都是。在伦敦，桥塌了，把女孩们聚在一起”
Never be a manly roar Crimp the light and candy On the sidewalks of New York But you kind of feel like when Robert Carroll is writing this, there are still old timers who when they hear that song they go, ah, yes, Al Smith. You know, the same way that I'll always think of Bill Clinton when I hear that, don't stop thinking about tomorrow's song when it comes on the oldies radio. And Governor Smith, he will work with reformers, but he works on reforms that are good politics. He has no time for the kind of uncompromising idealists that Moses used to traffic with. And he has some great names for them
“永远不会是男人的咆哮，卷曲的光和糖果，在纽约的人行道上”。但你确实觉得当罗伯特·卡罗写这段时，仍然有老派人物，当他们听到那首歌时，他们会说，啊，是的，阿尔·史密斯。你知道，就像我听到那首《别停止思考明天》（Don't Stop Thinking About Tomorrow）的歌在老歌电台上播放时，我总是会想到比尔·克林顿一样。而史密斯州长，他会与改革者合作，但他致力于那些是好政治的改革。他没时间理会摩西过去常打交道的那种不妥协的理想主义者。他给他们起了一些很棒的名字
that I want to highlight that he calls them Mushbrains, Double Dome, Crackpots, that's still around. And my favorite, which is Gugus. That is- Oh yeah, I love Gugus. You just won't, you just won't, won't deal with Gugus, doesn't want him. And at this point, the book has brought us back
我想强调一下，他称他们为“糊涂虫”（Mushbrains）、“双圆顶”（Double Dome）、“怪人”（Crackpots），这词现在还在用。还有我最喜欢的，“古古斯”（Gugus）。那是——哦，是的，我喜欢“古古斯”。你就是不会，你就是不会，不会和“古古斯”打交道，不想理他们。此时，这本书已经把我们带回了
to where we left off before. Moses is part of Smith's kind of coterie of people. He likes him. He likes singing barbershop quartet songs with him. Nobody really knows why. He just seems to like Robert Moses. And that's when we go back to the end of the last chapter. Smith loses the election. Moses accepts this job with the New York State Association. It's a new statewide good government organization. It's the first statewide good government reform organization in New York. And that instantly makes him a more important figure in that reform circle. He catches the eyes of the old reformers, the young lawyers. He's the embodiment of everything that they think is possible in the reform movement. This brilliant young hardworking
我们之前离开的地方。摩西是史密斯那种圈子的人。他喜欢他。他喜欢和他一起唱理发店四重唱歌曲。没人真正知道为什么。他似乎就是喜欢罗伯特·摩西。这就是我们回到上一章结尾的时候。史密斯输掉了选举。摩西接受了纽约州协会（New York State Association）的这份工作。这是一个新的全州范围的“好政府”组织。这是纽约第一个全州范围的“好政府”改革组织。这立刻使他成为那个改革圈子里更重要的人物。他引起了老改革者、年轻律师的注意。他是他们认为改革运动中一切可能性的化身。这个才华横溢、年轻勤奋的
guy who has strong principles, won't compromise, and he edits the organization's monthly magazine, which is very straightforward, reform principle-boosting, except when it comes to talking about Al Smith, in which case it is a super pro Al Smith magazine. And the other reformers are like, what is the deal? Like, I don't understand. Why? Why is that the one guy? And in 1922, Smith runs for governor again. The reform magazine is so solidly pro-Smith that it is making factual errors about Smith's opponent and Moses doesn't seem to care. It's so in the tank for Smith.
家伙，有坚定的原则，不妥协，他编辑了该组织的月刊，内容非常直截了当，提升改革原则，除了谈论阿尔·史密斯时，那种情况下它是一本超级支持阿尔·史密斯的杂志。其他改革者就想，这是怎么回事？就像，我不明白。为什么？为什么那个人是唯一的一个？1922年，史密斯再次竞选州长。改革杂志非常坚定地支持史密斯，以至于它在史密斯的对手身上犯了事实错误，而摩西似乎并不在乎。它对史密斯太死心塌地了。
And the other members of the government group who saw this as a nonpartisan organization, they're dismayed, they start to resign, the organization somewhat falls apart. And Robert Caron notes that 50 years later, when the book was written, the League of Women Voters was still the only statewide political reform organization in New York, that this organization, which had such potential, Moses effectively turned it into an Al Smith pack, you know, super pack. And I have to assume that's changed by now, but I did not do the research for it, that there must be a statewide reform organization in New York now.
而政府小组的其他成员，他们将此视为一个无党派组织，他们感到沮丧，他们开始辞职，该组织在某种程度上分崩离析。罗伯特·卡罗指出，50年后，当这本书写成时，妇女选民联盟（League of Women Voters）仍然是纽约唯一的全州政治改革组织，这个曾经有如此潜力的组织，摩西有效地把它变成了一个阿尔·史密斯的政治行动委员会（PAC），你知道，超级PAC。我必须假设现在情况已经改变了，但我没有为此做研究，现在纽约肯定有一个全州范围的改革组织。
And Robert Moses, he has made the ultimate change, which is that these other reformers, they come to him, they say, Al Smith said this in his speech, and it's not true, this thing win this election, right guys? And he has come to scorn anyone who prioritizes truth over results. And as Carol says, Bob Moses was scornful in short of what he had been. And Al Smith wins the election. Uh, and wrote Carol ends the chapter saying, and when on January 2nd, 1923, Al Smith went back to Albany, he took Bob Moses with him and he took him back big. Oh, I love that. He knows how to end chapters so well.
而罗伯特·摩西，他做出了最终的改变，那就是这些其他改革者，他们来到他面前，他们说，阿尔·史密斯在他的演讲中说了这个，这不是真的，这东西赢得了这次选举，对吧伙计们？他已经开始蔑视任何将真理置于结果之上的人。正如卡罗所说，鲍勃·摩西变得轻蔑，简而言之，他已经不是原来的他了。阿尔·史密斯赢得了选举。呃，罗伯特·卡罗以这样一句话结束了这一章：当1923年1月2日阿尔·史密斯回到奥尔巴尼时，他带上了鲍勃·摩西，而且带得很大。哦，我喜欢这个。他太知道怎么结束章节了。
It's a super chapter enter. Yeah. So now we're into chapter eight. It's called a taste of power. Um, and Al Smith is the governor again and Robert Moses is up in Albany with him. But in what is a very, for me was confusing the first time I read it, seeing, he's not sitting next to Al Smith in this, in the beginning of this chapter.
这是一个超级章节结尾。是的。所以现在我们进入第八章。它叫“权力的滋味”（A Taste of Power）。嗯，阿尔·史密斯又是州长了，罗伯特·摩西和他一起在奥尔巴尼。但在我第一次读时感到非常困惑的是，看到他在这章开头并没有坐在阿尔·史密斯旁边。
He's sitting next to a young Democrat named Jimmy Walker. Who is Jimmy Walker? At the time, Jimmy Walker is the, he's the Democratic floor leader in the legislature in the, in the state Senate. And you're right, it is super confusing that this guy is just brought in and Jimmy Walker will eventually be mayor of New York. He will and he is famous as the mayor who is, well, hear about him more, but he's a man about town. He's a songwriter. He is kind of the epitome of gentlemanly slimy corruption in New York City. He is a guy who dresses well. He takes his mistresses
他坐在一个叫吉米·沃克（Jimmy Walker）的年轻民主党人旁边。吉米·沃克是谁？当时，吉米·沃克是立法机关中，在州参议院的民主党领袖。你是对的，这个家伙突然被带进来确实非常令人困惑，吉米·沃克最终将成为纽约市长。他会的，而且他作为市长很有名，嗯，稍后会更多地听到关于他的事，但他是一个社交名流。他是一位作曲家。他某种程度上是纽约市绅士式卑劣腐败的缩影。他是一个穿着考究的家伙。他带着他的情妇
to official public events. He is, everybody loves him and he is super crooked. But here he's just kind of mentioned and he's mentioned in the way that I have to assume, what Robert Carroll is doing here is equivalent to when a Marvel movie ends and a character suddenly shows up and half the audience goes, oh, and the other half is like, I don't know who this is. Am I supposed to know who this is?
参加官方公开活动。他，每个人都喜欢他，而且他超级腐败。但在这里他只是被提到，而且他被提到的方式，我必须假设，罗伯特·卡罗在这里所做的等同于漫威电影结束时一个角色突然出现，一半观众说，哦，而另一半人像，我不知道这是谁。我应该知道这是谁吗？
Like this character shows his face for a moment that because Robert Carroll just assumes when he's writing for a New York audience in the 1970s, they know who Jimmy Walker is. Come on, he's famous. How could you forget about this, this indelible New York political character? And all I can think about is good times.
就像这个角色露了一面，因为罗伯特·卡罗在70年代为纽约观众写作时，他只是假设他们知道吉米·沃克是谁。拜托，他很有名。你怎么能忘记这个不可磨灭的纽约政治人物呢？我能想到的只有美好时光。
That all comes to mind when I hear Jimmy Walker. Once again, a New York political figures having the same name as a television actor has tripping us up again. Thanks a lot, reality for giving us so many of these. That's two in one episode. I'll say I just looked up a picture of Jimmy Walker. This guy does not look like you should trust him. Well, and that's in some ways he was kind of the way that Trump, part of the thing that people like about Trump when they like him, is that he's kind of a slime ball. You know, they kind of admire that about him. With Jimmy
当我听到吉米·沃克时，所有这些都会浮现在脑海中。再一次，一个纽约政治人物与电视演员同名，再次让我们绊倒。现实给了我们这么多这样的名字，真是太感谢了。这一集里有两个了。我会说我刚查了吉米·沃克的照片。这家伙看起来不像是你应该信任的人。嗯，在某种程度上，他有点像特朗普，人们喜欢特朗普的部分原因，当他们喜欢他时，是因为他有点像个卑鄙小人。你知道，他们有点钦佩他这一点。对于吉米
Walker, it was kind of the same thing where it was like, oh, Jimmy, oh, this guy, come on. Well, that's Jimmy, you know, that he was, he was very much the, the, the arch nemesis of a lot of reformers at the time. But this is before he's become mayor. This is when he is still a Democratic Senator. But Robert Moses is doing the job in this scene of being the guy who stands next to the politician and tells him all the things that he needs to know job, his only salary is as secretary of the New York State Association. But effectively, his role is as Al Smith's legislative researcher, messenger, all around companion, like right-hand man in a lot of ways. He's in the building with Al Smith at work. He goes with Al Smith to visit Al Smith's grandkids. He goes with Al Smith at night to visit the animals in the executive mansion, Menagerie, which apparently was something that they had at the time of the Executive
沃克，情况也差不多，就像，哦，吉米，哦，这家伙，拜托。嗯，那就是吉米，你知道，他非常是当时许多改革者的死对头。但这在他成为市长之前。这是当他还是民主党参议员的时候。但罗伯特·摩西在这一幕中扮演的角色是站在政治家旁边，告诉他所有他需要知道的事情，他的唯一薪水是作为纽约州协会的秘书。但实际上，他的角色是阿尔·史密斯的立法研究员、信使、全能的同伴，在很多方面是得力助手。他在大楼里和阿尔·史密斯一起工作。他陪阿尔·史密斯去探望阿尔·史密斯的孙辈。他晚上陪阿尔·史密斯去参观行政官邸的动物园，这显然是他们当时在行政官邸拥有的东西
Mansion. And it's possibly the least relevant piece of information, but I feel like I have to highlight the animals that were living outside the Executive Mansion in Albany at the time, which was, let's see, tiger and bear cubs, goats, a fox and an elk, and as permanent resident, six dogs, a mother raccoon with three baby raccoons and three monkeys So at this point there's the the the governor of New York has a private zoo and Al Smith loves it This will come up later. He's love of zoos But Moses is in the political inner circle. It's him. It's mrs. Moskowitz. It's a few other people Tammany bosses and reformers He is in the mix of power
这可能是最不相关的信息，但我觉得我必须强调当时住在奥尔巴尼行政官邸外的动物，那是，让我们看看，老虎和熊崽、山羊、狐狸和麋鹿，作为常驻居民，六只狗、一只带着三只小浣熊的浣熊妈妈和三只猴子。所以此时，纽约州州长有一个私人动物园，阿尔·史密斯很喜欢它。这稍后会提到。他对动物园的热爱。但摩西在政治核心圈子里。是他，是莫斯科维茨夫人（Mrs. Moskowitz），还有其他几个人，坦慕尼老板和改革者。他处于权力的中心
Jamel is this how things still work that there's like just unpaid people wandering around with politicians? I mean, like, I feel like when I watch cable news, which I try not to, because it depresses me, there's always people who are credited as like political consultant or advisor. Is this the kind of thing that Robert Moses was just kind of like a free floating kind of unpaid but very necessary advisor. Do we still have that? We still, I mean, often the people who fill that role are paid these days, mostly because a politician, right, like your top campaign advisor, you may bring on a staff, right? Like maybe you'll be your chief of staff. Maybe we'll serve some other like staff position that they can be paid. They kind of just sort of guy who's around who doesn't really have a job, but gets close to the governor or to the
贾梅尔，事情现在还是这样运作的吗，就是有一些无薪的人在政治家身边游荡？我的意思是，我觉得当我观看有线电视新闻时，我尽量不看，因为它让我沮丧，总有人被冠以政治顾问或顾问的头衔。这就是罗伯特·摩西那种有点像自由漂浮的、无薪但非常必要的顾问吗？我们现在还有吗？我们仍然，我的意思是，通常担任那个角色的人现在是有报酬的，主要是因为政治家，对吧，比如你的顶级竞选顾问，你可能会带上一个团队，对吧？比如你可能会成为你的幕僚长。也许我们会担任其他一些可以获得报酬的职位。他们只是那种在身边晃悠、没有真正工作，但却接近州长或
mayor or to whomever. I feel like it's a little less common these days. That kind of close advisor still around, but they are often given some kind of official role just to put them in proximity and give them like a paycheck. Patronage is still a thing. But now it's good white collar kind of like expert patronage as opposed to the bad old fashioned regular people get jobs patronage, right? Right, right, right, right. Oh, thank goodness. I'll just say even white collar patron white color, people still feel like someone needs to have qualifications. I don't know if you remember George W. Bush's first pick for Supreme Court after
市长或任何人的家伙。我觉得现在这种情况少了一些。那种亲密的顾问仍然存在，但他们通常会被赋予某种官方角色，只是为了让他们靠近并给他们发工资。赞助仍然是一回事。但现在它是好的白领那种专家赞助，而不是那种坏的、老式的普通人得到工作的赞助，对吧？对，对，对，对。哦，谢天谢地。我只想说，即使是白领赞助，人们仍然觉得某人需要具备资格。我不确定你是否记得乔治·W·布什在桑德拉·戴·奥康纳（Sandra Day O'Connor）之后对最高法院的第一次提名，哈里特·迈尔斯（Harriet Miers），她是他的私人律师。当时就像，是的，我会把我的私人律师放在法院。为什么不呢？这就像经典的赞助。这就像是经典的赞助，而且我不认为这是一件坏事。我认为，我的意思是，我想我们可能都会过得更好，如果那是哈里特·迈尔斯大法官，而不是塞缪尔·阿利托（Sam Alito）大法官。是的，那，那才是令人惊奇的事情，就像理论上
Sandra Day O'Connor, Harry Myers, who was his personal lawyer. And it was like, yeah, I'll put my personal lawyer on the court. Why not? That's like classic patronage. It's like it's class classic patronage And I don't think it's a bad thing I think it's like I think I mean I think we probably would have all been better off if it was Justice Harriet Myers But not Justice Samolito. Yeah, that's well, that's the amazing thing is it's like in theory That's bonkers for the president put his personal lawyer someone who does did not seem to have the experience Nobody knew really what her ideas were to put on it But looking at back on it now, I'm like, you know what?
总统把他的私人律师，一个似乎没有经验、没人真正知道她的想法的人放在那里是疯狂的。但现在回想起来，我像，你知道吗？
It probably would have been better to have just like a personal attorney who is not beholden to the like the Federalist Society or some, didn't clerk for a Supreme Court justice like to have them on the court. But maybe we need more of that stuff. I don't know. This is actually the point I was gonna make.
如果有一个不被联邦党人协会（Federalist Society）之类的人所左右，没有为最高法院大法官做过书记员的私人律师在法院，可能反而会更好。但也许我们需要更多那种东西。我不知道。这实际上是我要提出的观点。
That sort of, what we gain stuff, the legacy of this reform movement is the professionalization of government service. And we gain a lot from that. That is important. But these are political jobs at the end of the day. And political considerations do have a place in political jobs. And I think we lose something in trying to get rid of political considerations in political jobs. There's a balance to strike. And sometimes I think with certain kinds of positions, we've moved way too far in the direction of everyone has to be a certain kind of professional versus in the case of a Supreme Court seat or the federal judiciary in general, hey, maybe it's not a bad idea to appoint someone who was a long time legislator to this job.
那种，我们获得的东西，这场改革运动的遗产是政府服务的专业化。我们从中获益良多。这很重要。但归根结底，这些是政治工作。而政治考量在政治工作中确实有一席之地。我认为我们在试图摆脱政治工作中的政治考量时失去了一些东西。需要达成一种平衡。有时我认为对于某些职位，我们在“每个人都必须是某种专业人士”的方向上走得太远了，而在最高法院席位或整个联邦司法机构的情况下，嘿，任命一个长期担任立法者的人担任这个职位，也许不是一个坏主意。
They can figure out the technical parts, but we're not hiring them for their judgment. And maybe that's what we're looking for. Well, that's the way they were doing things in the old days. And Robert Carrot talks about the excitement for Moses of working in Smith's office. He's in the center of power in the state, and he's seeing how real decisions are being made. He's seen the practical considerations that go into these bills, like you're talking about, into these decisions. And it's exciting for him because he knows now that none of his ideas matter if he doesn't have executive support. When he was
他们可以弄清楚技术部分，但我们雇佣他们不是为了他们的判断力。也许这就是我们正在寻找的。嗯，这就是他们过去做事的方式。罗伯特·卡罗谈到了摩西在史密斯办公室工作的兴奋感。他处于该州权力的中心，他看到了真正的决策是如何做出的。他看到了这些法案中包含的实际考量，就像你谈到的，这些决策中。这对他来说很令人兴奋，因为他现在知道，如果他没有行政支持，他的任何想法都不重要。当他
pushing that civil service reform and the boy mayor John Perry Mitchell just wouldn't back it up. It died. But now he knows if he has a good idea that can get Al Smith a political benefit and also will help people, Al Smith will put his support behind it. And he starts getting things done. And the things are not the things that we associate Robert Moses with yet. There's prison reform and especially juvenile detention reform. And a lot of elimination of ground level railroad track crossings, which were incredibly deadly and yet all over the place, that the trains were constantly hitting people,
推动公务员改革时，男孩市长约翰·珀里·米切尔（John Purroy Mitchel）就是不支持它。它就夭折了。但现在他知道，如果他有一个好的想法，可以给阿尔·史密斯带来政治利益，同时也能帮助人们，阿尔·史密斯会支持它。他开始把事情做成了。而这些事情还不是我们现在与罗伯特·摩西联系在一起的事情。有监狱改革，特别是少年拘留改革。还有大量消除地面铁路道口的工作，这些道口极其致命，却到处都是，火车不断地撞到人，
but it took a lot of effort to get those removed. And they eventually win that government reorganization fight that started Smith's first term and they get those bills. And Moses is doing a lot of the bill drafting here. And there's a second here that describes what we were talking about earlier, that kind of like specialized knowledge of how bills go that I would love to read to you guys. And then we can cut it later, but you'll know that I read it to you. And it'll live with you forever until your dying day. Where it says, live with you forever until until your dying day. Where it says,
但要移除这些障碍费了很大力气。他们最终赢得了史密斯第一任期开始时的那场政府重组之战，并拿到了那些法案。摩西在这里负责了大量的法案起草工作。这里有一段话描述了我们之前谈到的那种关于法案如何运作的专业知识，我很想读给你们听。之后我们可以把它剪掉，但你们会知道我读给你们听过。它会永远留在你们心中，直到你们临终的那一天。文中写道，永远留在你们心中，直到你们临终的那一天。文中写道，
Bill drafting was called by Albany insiders the black art of politics. An expert bill drafter had to know thousands of precedents so that he could call out the one embodying it in the bill he was working on that would make the bill legal or so that he could by careful wording avoid bringing the new act within the purview of an old one that might make it illegal. He had to know a myriad ways of conferring or denying power by written words. He had to know how to lull the opposition by concealing a bill's real content. For years, everyone had known the identity of the best bill drafter in Albany, Alfred E. Smith, and Smith had never been shy about accepting that accolade. But now, when someone brought up the subject, Smith said, the best bill drafter I know is Bob Moses. So he's making a name for himself as the guy who can write laws that get things done and that work the right way. And Al Smith
法案起草被奥尔巴尼的内部人士称为政治的“黑魔法”。一位专业的法案起草人必须了解成千上万的先例，这样他才能在起草法案时引用其中一条，使法案合法化；或者通过谨慎的措辞，避免将新法案纳入旧法案的管辖范围，以免使其变得非法。他必须掌握无数种通过书面文字授予或剥夺权力的方法。他必须知道如何通过隐瞒法案的真实内容来安抚反对派。多年来，每个人都知道奥尔巴尼最好的法案起草人是阿尔弗雷德·E·史密斯，而史密斯从不羞于接受这一赞誉。但现在，当有人提起这个话题时，史密斯说：“我所知道的最好的法案起草人是鲍勃·摩西。”所以，他正在以一个能够撰写出切实可行且运作良好的法律的人而闻名。而阿尔·史密斯
wants to repay Moses the way that he's used to repaying people in these positions, which is with a high paying, low work job. He's like, Hey, do you want to be director of the board that supervises the work projects in the state prisons? You don't have to do anything and you'll get paid money for it. And Moses says, No, I don't want that. And Al Smith keeps asking Moses, What do you want? What do you want? What do you want? What can I get you? What can I reward you with? And Moses keeps saying nothing. And then the chapter ends with one of these lines. Robert Carroll, he writes it, This is one of these things where it's like, it's a real like, oh, what moment? But only in this context says,
想要以他习惯的方式回报摩西，即提供一份高薪、轻松的工作。他说：“嘿，你想成为监管州立监狱工作项目的委员会主任吗？你什么都不用做，就能拿到钱。”摩西说：“不，我不想要那个。”阿尔·史密斯不断地问摩西：“你想要什么？你想要什么？你想要什么？我能给你什么？我能用什么来奖励你？”摩西一直说“什么都不要”。然后这一章以这样一句话结尾。罗伯特·卡罗写道，这就像是那种让人惊叹的时刻，但只有在这种语境下才会说，
and then one day there was something. The something was Parks. We're 143 pages into the book. We're finally talking about Parks. The thing that he does, it's amazing. We're here finally with chapter nine, a dream. We'll get to that chapter after this quick break. Okay, so now we're starting with Chapter 9.
然后有一天，机会来了。这个机会就是公园。我们已经读到书的第143页了。我们终于在谈论公园了。他所做的事情真是太棒了。我们终于来到了第九章，“梦想”。在短暂休息后，我们将进入那一章。好了，现在我们开始第九章。
This is not the longest chapter in the book, but it's the longest one we've encountered so far. And it really sets up this idea that as New York was growing, there was always more land to be considered and there was open land and natural areas for people to potentially go to. But New York is growing so fast, all that stuff is filling in and all of a sudden people are like,
这不是书中篇幅最长的一章，但却是我们目前为止遇到的最长的一章。它确实提出了这样一个观点：随着纽约的发展，总有更多的土地需要考虑，而且有空地和自然区域供人们潜在地前往。但纽约发展得太快了，所有这些地方都在被填满，突然之间人们意识到，
whoa, we need to get to some parks. We need to take care of parks here. You know what I used to see around here? Trees, I don't see them so much anymore. I'd like to see some. We gotta figure out a place to have some. I mean, it's hard to imagine it now, but New York wasn't always this densely packed
哇，我们需要去一些公园。我们需要在这里打理公园。你知道我以前在这里看到什么吗？树木，我现在不怎么看到了。我想看一些。我们得找个地方弄一些。我的意思是，现在很难想象，但纽约并不总是如此拥挤，
with all these buildings and streets. When I lived in New York, I would walk around a lot and think about what part of what I'm standing on is natural geography, what hills and what dips are natural geography, and what things were added by human beings. Because once this was all forest land, once this is all forest and marsh and now it is entirely covered in in paving. And this is the period when that those final bits of paving are starting to be done that open space that the city used to have is being filled in with housing developments. And at the same time, there's all this new technology that means people finally have a little bit of leisure time, the days of working at the Fulton Fish Market,
到处都是建筑和街道。当我住在纽约时，我经常四处走动，思考我脚下的哪一部分是自然地理，哪些山丘和洼地是自然地理，哪些是人类添加的。因为这里曾经全是森林，曾经全是森林和沼泽，而现在完全被铺路石覆盖了。而这段时期正是那些最后的铺路工作开始的时候，城市曾经拥有的开放空间正在被住房开发项目填满。与此同时，所有这些新技术意味着人们终于有了一点闲暇时间，在富尔顿鱼市场工作的日子，
seven days a week, 4 a.m. to 5 p.m. at 3 a.m. on Fridays, that's starting to come to an end. People have cars for the first time. They can actually leave the city if they want to, to go places. This is amazing. They need something to do with their leisure. Only problem is is amazing. They need something to do with their leisure. Only problem is most of the good land right outside of the city is in private hands. And the public land that you could use as recreation gets too hard to get to. There's literally very little actual road work to get there. The roads are poor, the bridges across the rivers are tiny. The only way to get west across the Hudson River is to take your car on a ferry, which has to be the least efficient way to do that other than to put, I guess, balloons under your car and float it across the river with an ore and make it its own ferry. And
每周七天，凌晨4点到下午5点，周五凌晨3点，那样的日子开始走向终点。人们第一次有了汽车。如果他们愿意，他们实际上可以离开城市去别的地方。这太棒了。他们需要利用闲暇时间做点什么。唯一的问题是，大多数城市外的好土地都掌握在私人手中。而你可以作为休闲场所使用的公共土地却太难到达了。实际上几乎没有什么像样的道路可以到达那里。道路很差，横跨河流的桥梁很小。向西穿过哈德逊河的唯一方法是把车开上渡轮，这一定是最没效率的方法，除非你在车下绑上气球，用桨划着它漂过河，让它成为自己的渡轮。而且
to the east is Long Island. And Robert Carr talks about this kind of open potential in Long Island. Long Island is this place that still has space. First, he talks about how the Ice Age created Long Island's geography. And I got to say, that's the one, maybe the two pages of this book I find my eyes really glazing over where I'm like, oh, I just can't visualize it. I can't believe it. I love that part. And I'll tell you why. Because this is the first instance of Robert Carroll, the author, using geography as a piece of a key piece of biographical text. Because in the opening chapter of the first LPJ book, it's all about the Texas Hill Country's soil composition and potential fecundity,
向东是长岛。罗伯特·卡罗谈到了长岛这种开放的潜力。长岛是一个仍然有空间的地方。首先，他谈到了冰河时代是如何塑造长岛地理的。我必须说，这是这本书中可能有一两页让我感到眼花缭乱的地方，我心想，哦，我简直无法想象。我无法相信。我喜欢那部分。我告诉你们为什么。因为这是罗伯特·卡罗（作者）第一次将地理作为传记文本的关键部分。因为在第一本《林登·约翰逊传》的第一章中，全是关于德克萨斯丘陵地带的土壤成分和潜在的肥力，
which creates Johnson as a person. And so, when I see this echo of Caro's style, I get pretty excited, even if I don't, you know, like if the details of the Ice Age forming the Long Island Sound does not stick in my head. Well, he's talking about this, I'm like, all right, Mr. Carrow, I respect so much that you put this effort in and you understood how the rock formations came across, but I'll just move on to the next place. The point is Long Island looks like it would be a great place
这塑造了约翰逊这个人。所以，当我看到卡罗风格的这种回响时，我感到非常兴奋，即使我并没有，你知道，即使冰河时代形成长岛海湾的细节没有留在我的脑海里。好吧，他在谈论这个时，我心想，好吧，卡罗先生，我非常尊重你投入的这些努力，你理解岩层是如何形成的，但我还是会跳到下一个地方。重点是长岛看起来会是一个好地方，
to spend your one day off from work with your family, right? Right, but you can't. No, you can't, unfortunately, because Long Island is taken. Who's it taken by? There's the South Shore where you have the beaches, they're in the hands of the Baymen, these kind of fishermen who have lived in that area for generations and they do not want outsiders there. They don't like people from New York
可以带着家人度过你一周中唯一的一天假，对吧？对，但你不能。不，不幸的是你不能，因为长岛被占用了。被谁占用了？南岸有海滩，它们掌握在“湾民”手中，这些渔民在那一带生活了几代人，他们不希望外人进入。他们不喜欢来自纽约市的人，
City. Robert Carroll presents them as especially careful to keep sacred the Bay bottoms, the actual fishing area that they see as their birthright. He presents them as fairly racist and also talks about the clans popularity there. And I sometimes wonder if Robert Caro is going really far to demonize these fishermen. But I can't tell for sure because this is 100 years ago. I can't talk to them. They're not there anymore. That's the South Shore. You've got your, for lack of a better word, your kind of provincials. Then up in the North Shore, Shore, it's even worse. That's where the land is locked up by the private estates of the wealthy Robert Barons. J.P. Morgan's family and his partners are there. We've got Standard Oil Millionaires, Andrew Carnegie's partner. There's a lot of them. Robert Carroll, he loves to list things. He goes through all of these rich people and what they own. He talks a lot about the size of their castles,
罗伯特·卡罗指出他们特别小心地保护着海湾底部，即他们视为与生俱来的权利的实际捕鱼区。他把他们描述得相当种族主义，还谈到了三K党在那里很受欢迎。我有时怀疑罗伯特·卡罗是否走得太远，把这些渔民妖魔化了。但我无法确定，因为那是100年前的事了。我无法与他们交谈。他们已经不在那里了。那是南岸。你有你的，用一个更好的词来说，你的那种“乡下人”。然后在北岸，情况更糟。那里的土地被富有的工业大亨的私人庄园锁住了。J.P.摩根的家族和他的合伙人都在那里。我们有标准石油公司的百万富翁，安德鲁·卡内基的合伙人。他们有很多。罗伯特·卡罗，他喜欢列举事物。他历数了所有这些富人以及他们拥有的东西。他谈了很多关于他们城堡的大小，
how they would go fox hunting there. They build a private golf course that's surprisingly full of mosquitoes, they own vast amounts of land, and then they own more land around that land that is guarded by private guards to keep regular people away from them. And they especially seem to enjoy blocking access to the beaches. And Robert Cowell points out that there's one area of Long Island where there was 48 miles of shoreline and 1,250 feet were open to the public and the rest was all in private, wealthy hands. And the Barons of the North Shore, they want to keep things this way and they do that by essentially bankrolling the state GOP. The Republican Party, specifically the Nassau County Republican Party, is very much a machine that works at the behest of the Barons to keep them in control of all this land.
他们是如何在那里进行猎狐的。他们建造了一个出人意料地充满蚊子的私人高尔夫球场，他们拥有大量的土地，然后在这些土地周围又拥有更多的土地，由私人警卫守卫，以防止普通人靠近。他们似乎特别喜欢阻挡通往海滩的道路。罗伯特·卡罗指出，长岛有一个地区，那里有48英里的海岸线，只有1250英尺对公众开放，其余的都掌握在富有的私人手中。而北岸的大亨们，他们想保持这种状态，他们通过本质上资助州共和党来做到这一点。共和党，特别是拿骚县共和党，在很大程度上是一个听命于大亨们的机器，以保持他们对所有这些土地的控制。
And Robert Carroll, he has this amazingly vivid section. This is one of the sections of the book that I always remember the most when I think about it, that is him describing the experience of you being a guy taking your family in your car on the weekend to drive out to Long Island to find a place to have a picnic and just how incredibly feudal it is to do this and I'd love to read some of it if they were heading for the North Shore on Northern Boulevard
罗伯特·卡罗有一段极其生动的描写。这是我想到这本书时记忆最深刻的片段之一，那就是他描述了一个人周末带着家人开车去长岛寻找野餐地点时的经历，以及这样做是多么的封建。如果他们正沿着北方大道前往北岸，我很想读其中的一些内容，
160 feet of smooth McAdams shrank to 18 at the city line The cars heading east had to cram into a single file as they crept along the paving of the boulevard deteriorated So that each family had to watch the cars ahead jounce one after the other into gaping potholes and then wait for the jolts themselves. More and more frequently they came to unpaved stretches in which, if there had been a recent rain, cars became mired, bringing the endless line behind them to a halt. If the earth was dry, thick clouds of dust hung over the unpaved stretches, turning
160英尺宽的平坦碎石路在城市边界缩减到了18英尺。向东行驶的汽车不得不挤成单行，沿着破损的大道铺装路面缓慢爬行，以至于每个家庭都不得不看着前面的车一辆接一辆地颠簸进巨大的坑洼中，然后等待自己也经历同样的颠簸。他们越来越频繁地遇到未铺砌的路段，如果最近下过雨，汽车就会陷入泥潭，导致后面无尽的车队停滞不前。如果地面干燥，未铺砌的路段上空悬浮着厚厚的尘云，把
dirty the gay dress mother had worn for the excursion. As the families drove, they could see on either side of them through gates set in stone walls or through the openings and wooden fences, the beautiful meadows they had come for, stretching endlessly and empty to the cool trees beyond. But the meadows and trees were not for them. The gates would be locked, and men carrying shotguns and holding fierce dogs on straining leashes would point eastward, telling the families there were parks open to them,
母亲为这次出游穿的漂亮衣服弄脏了。当家庭开车行驶时，他们可以看到道路两旁，透过石墙上的大门或木栅栏的缝隙，看到他们所追求的美丽草地，空旷地延伸到远处的凉爽树木。但草地和树木不属于他们。大门会被锁上，带着猎枪、牵着拉紧皮带的凶猛狗的男人们会指向东方，告诉这些家庭，前面有对他们开放的公园，
farther along. There was no shade on northern Boulevard, and the children became cranky early. The more persistent who determined to head east until they discovered some place to swim or picnic found the road becoming worse and worse. They would see long island villagers sitting on the fences and laughing at the families, who, because of engine overheating or in a desperate try at a piece of grass pulled off the road. The line of cars was so solid, the radiator of one almost touching the tailgate of the one before it that once out of the line, it was hard for a car to get back in. And it was fun, the villagers said to watch them try. Just like all the all the elements of a really terrible outing with your family are there so vividly to me where it's like, it was supposed to be nice. It's not working out. It's hot.
再往前走。北方大道上没有树荫，孩子们很早就变得烦躁不安。那些坚持要向东行驶直到找到游泳或野餐地点的人发现道路变得越来越糟。他们会看到长岛村民坐在栅栏上，嘲笑那些因为引擎过热或绝望地想找一块草地而驶离道路的家庭。车队如此拥挤，一辆车的散热器几乎触碰到前面一辆车的后挡板，以至于一旦离开车队，汽车就很难再挤进去。村民们说，看着他们尝试很有趣。就像所有那些与家人进行一次真正糟糕出游的元素都如此生动地呈现在我面前，感觉就像，它本应该是美好的。但结果却不尽如人意。天气很热。
It's gross. And the locals are laughing at you and you're trapped there. You're stuck. And I think, you know, we're all fathers, right? We've all been in situations where we want to do something nice with our families and nothing is working out right. And I feel like Robert Carrot does such a good job to me at least of of taking this big issue of public space and how it's allocated and what's public space and what's private space and making it really relatable in that experience of, like, we just want to go somewhere outside the city today. And instead, we're going to end up spending the entire day in the car and then we have to go back and it's terrible.
这很恶心。当地人在嘲笑你，而你被困在那里。你被困住了。我想，你知道，我们都是父亲，对吧？我们都经历过想要和家人做点好事却什么都不顺利的情况。我觉得罗伯特·卡罗做得非常好，至少对我来说，他把公共空间这个大问题，以及它是如何分配的，什么是公共空间，什么是私人空间，通过那种“我们今天只想去城外某个地方”的经历，变得非常容易产生共鸣。结果我们最终要在车里度过一整天，然后我们不得不回去，这太糟糕了。
The point is that people need parks. Long Island is the best place for them. But building a park there means you have to get the state legislature involved. They're in the control of the barons. The land is too valuable for the government to buy. It's too valuable for them to condemn it. They can't afford it. And if you did build parks, even if you did, how would anybody get out there?
重点是人们需要公园。长岛是最好的地方。但在那里建公园意味着你必须让州议会参与进来。他们在大亨们的控制之下。土地太值钱了，政府买不起。他们无法征用。他们负担不起。即使你真的建了公园，即使你建了，谁又能去那里呢？
The roads are so bad. And so the reformers who talk about parks, they have to settle for kind of like little city playgrounds. There's nobody who's going to be able to cut this Gordian park knot. Except there is one man. One man? Who would that man be? His name is Robert Moses. And in 1922. So it's 1922 Robert Moses and his wife, Mary, they're renting a bungalow in Babylon, Long Island. And this is one of the few times you actually see Robert Moses on a train. Yes. Yes. He has to take the Long Island railroad from Manhattan to Long Island, the same railroad
道路太差了。所以，谈论公园的改革者们不得不满足于像城市小操场那样的地方。没有人能够解开这个戈耳狄俄斯之结。除了一个人。一个人？那个人会是谁？他的名字叫罗伯特·摩西。1922年。所以那是1922年，罗伯特·摩西和他的妻子玛丽在长岛巴比伦租了一间平房。这是你极少数能看到罗伯特·摩西坐火车的时候之一。是的。是的。他必须乘坐长岛铁路从曼哈顿到长岛，也就是那条
he will years later help to push into deterioration and almost to disintegration with his road building and as he's taking this long train ride He's looking out the window to the what he can see north of the railroad and he realizes he's passing all this untouched land There's housing in towns, but in between it. There's ponds and woods and streams. There's just land that is just sitting there Nobody's doing anything with it. Yeah, this land get there Well, this is what's the most amazing thing is like he does his he does some research and he goes to the Babylon Town Hall And he's told this property was bought by the city of Brooklyn when when it was its own independent city in 1874 and it was the emergency backup water reservoir in case you know the city needed extra water and so he goes to the Department of Water and he asked the clerk, have they ever used it? And he says no. And it's just sitting there. It's undeveloped.
他多年后将通过他的筑路工程推动其走向衰退甚至几乎解体的铁路。当他坐着这趟长途火车时，他看着窗外铁路北侧的景象，意识到他经过了所有这些未受触动的土地。城镇里有住房，但在城镇之间，有池塘、树林和溪流。那里只是有土地静静地躺在那里，没有人利用它。是的，这片土地怎么会这样？好吧，最令人惊奇的是，他做了一些研究，去了巴比伦市政厅，被告知这处房产是布鲁克林市在1874年还是一个独立城市时购买的，它是紧急备用水库，以防城市需要额外的水。所以他去了水务部门，问职员，他们用过吗？他说没有。它就那样闲置着。它是未开发的。
And Moses can't help but think to himself, I've got to look at it. I've got to see how much of this there is. And he decides to just hike through Long Island, just on his own. He's just tromping through the woods and it turns out every time he thinks he's figured out how much land there is, there's more. It's so much more extensive than he thought it was. It's so much more beautiful than he thought it was. There's so much of it. Yeah. There's 3,500 unused acres. There's just sitting there and it's within 30 miles of Manhattan and he really
摩西不禁心想，我得去看看。我得看看这片土地有多少。他决定独自徒步穿越长岛。他只是在树林里跋涉，结果每次他以为自己算出了有多少土地时，还有更多。它比他想象的要广阔得多。它比他想象的要美丽得多。有太多了。是的。有3500英亩未使用的土地。它就静静地躺在那里，距离曼哈顿不到30英里，他真的
starts to, you know, create this vision of parks and sports facilities, and it's all right there. And he gets a motorboat, like a little motorboat, and he begins to explore the shoreline. And these are the most vehicles that Robert Moses will use in the entire, but this, he is piloting this motorboat. He's never going to drive a car, but he can apparently drive a boat, which is, which I don't know why he didn't transfer those skills to cars, but he stuck with boats. He just can't help exploring and he gets almost obsessed with it.
开始，你知道，创造这种公园和体育设施的愿景，而且一切都在那里。他弄到了一艘摩托艇，像一艘小摩托艇，开始探索海岸线。这些是罗伯特·摩西在整个过程中会使用的最主要的交通工具，但他正在驾驶这艘摩托艇。他从不学开车，但他显然会开船，我不知道为什么他没有把这些技能转移到汽车上，但他坚持用船。他只是忍不住去探索，他几乎对此着迷了。
He's he is spending all of his time just pioneering through Long Island, this land that nobody has bothered to look at in such a long time. And because of the sort of, I don't know, hydrology and geology, there's actually more beach and more land than even the map makers had when they last surveyed it than he thought. And he gets obsessed with this little area, this area called Jones Beach. It's this huge untouched stretch of shoreline. And he says to himself, this would be the greatest bathing beach in the world. This could be, but it's totally unused. It's totally untouched. There's only two problems. One, how do I turn this stretch of beach into the greatest bathing beach in the world? And two, even if I do that, how do I get people there?
他把所有时间都花在长岛上，探索这片很久没有人去看的土地。由于某种，我不知道，水文学和地质学的原因，实际上有比地图绘制者上次测量时更多的海滩和土地。他迷上了这个小区域，这个叫琼斯海滩的地方。这是一片巨大的、未受触动的海岸线。他对自己说，这将是世界上最棒的沐浴海滩。这本可以，但它完全没有被利用。它完全没有被触动。只有两个问题。第一，我如何把这片海滩变成世界上最棒的沐浴海滩？第二，即使我做到了，我怎么让人们去那里？
Because the reason this lane is so untouched is partly because the city owns it and no one knew that, but also partly because there's no roads out there. He had to take the train to get where he was going and you can't just turn a train and drive to a new area. You need roads to get there. And so now as he is tromping through Long Island, he is drawing on pads, drawing on maps, these parkway lines,
因为这片土地之所以如此未受触动，部分原因是城市拥有它，没人知道这一点，但也部分因为那里没有道路。他必须坐火车才能到达目的地，你不能只是转动火车就开到新区域。你需要道路才能到达那里。所以现在，当他在长岛跋涉时，他在垫子上、地图上画着这些公园大道的线路，
lines for imaginary parkways that he is envisioning, the same way that Robert Carroll told us in the previous episode that he was still doing years later. He just could not stop drawing lines on maps that represented roads. This is where he starts to do that really for the first time. And he's spending so much of his time doing it. It really makes you wonder, like how does he have time to do his job? And to be at Albany, he's a very busy man. And he somehow has time to just wanderlust through Long Island,
他所设想的虚构公园大道的线路，就像罗伯特·卡罗在上一集中告诉我们的那样，他多年后仍然在这样做。他就是无法停止在地图上画代表道路的线条。这是他第一次真正开始这样做。他花了很多时间在上面。这真的让你想知道，他怎么有时间做他的工作？而且在奥尔巴尼，他是一个非常忙碌的人。他不知何故有时间在长岛漫游，
drawing imaginary parkways. This guy, he's just really good at using his time. He seems to be, and other people don't seem to be demanding too much of his time. It seems like. Hey, boss, can I just go walk around Long Island Park a place? You got it. You're the best bill drafter in Albany. I don't need you for anything else.
画着虚构的公园大道。这家伙，他真的很擅长利用时间。他似乎是，而且其他人似乎并没有对他要求太多时间。看起来是这样。嘿，老板，我能去长岛公园逛逛吗？没问题。你是奥尔巴尼最好的法案起草人。我不需要你做别的事。
And there were a few state parks at the time. Robert Harrow goes into this that in the early 1920s, there were a few small state parks in the hands of local associations because the state basically didn't want to handle the responsibility. So they would say like, great, this land, you can take care of it. You want to be the caretakers, this local historical association, whatever, go for it. And Moses says, this is a dissipation of power instead of one major parks organization that has political muscle behind it. You have these competing little tiny private organizations that the legislature doesn't want to give money to because they can't really control it. And through the New York State Association, Moses issues a report that sums up all this called a State Park Plan for New York,
当时有几个州立公园。罗伯特·卡罗深入探讨了这一点，在20世纪20年代初，有几个小的州立公园掌握在当地协会手中，因为州政府基本上不想处理这个责任。所以他们会说，太好了，这片土地，你们可以照顾它。你们想成为看管人吗，这个当地历史协会，随便什么，去吧。摩西说，这是一种权力的分散，而不是一个拥有政治肌肉的单一大型公园组织。你有这些相互竞争的小型私人组织，立法机构不想给他们钱，因为他们无法真正控制它。通过纽约州协会，摩西发布了一份总结这一切的报告，名为《纽约州公园计划》，
a beautiful name for a beautiful report just to just really gets the blood pumping, the State Park Plan. I want to bring in a Jamel here for a second and a lot of like- I'll allow it. Our political history is about our relationship with land. And there was a sort of national parks movement associated with Teddy Roosevelt before this. And then there's also like the use of common land. And that was sort of like disrupted by barbed wire, in the West. Where are we in our thinking of public land at this point in time
一个美丽的名字，一份美丽的报告，真的让人热血沸腾，《州公园计划》。我想请贾梅尔进来一下，很多-我允许。我们的政治历史就是关于我们与土地的关系。在此之前，有一种与西奥多·罗斯福相关的国家公园运动。然后还有像公共土地的使用。而在西部，那被铁丝网破坏了。在这一历史时刻，我们对公共土地的思考处于什么位置？
in our political history? We're an interesting point. I mean, one of the things that is structuring how Americans are thinking about public land is just that the frontier, as they understood it, does not exist anymore. There's no West for the young man to go to everything's been settled. And there were also sort of in this age of industrial capitalism. And so all around the country, and especially in places that are well populated, you're seeing the, you know, the, the march of industry, the use of natural resources and the growth of the country's productive capacities. And for many Americans, and the political elite, this is all well and good, right? This is
我们处于一个有趣的节点。我的意思是，构建美国人如何思考公共土地的事情之一就是，他们所理解的“边疆”已经不存在了。没有西部供年轻人去开拓了，一切都已定居。而且我们还处于工业资本主义时代。所以全国各地，特别是在人口稠密的地区，你看到了工业的推进，自然资源的使用和国家生产能力的增长。对于许多美国人和政治精英来说，这一切都很好，对吧？这
like, this is the way things ought to be. But there is like this anxiety about what's being lost. One like interesting social wrinkle here is that the early 20th century, there are these recurring panics in the United States over whether young men are manly enough and like this is one of them is happening sort of like, oh, okay, are enough. And like, this is, this is one of them is happening sort of like, Oh, okay, our, our America is young men, are they being feminized? Are they spending enough time outside? Are they, you know, engaged in mainly pursuits? Or are they sort of reading books and being inside and all these sorts of things? This feels like a direct attack on me. But I understand. Yeah. All of this really does come together in all this is not I want to say come together, but it's part of this push for
就像，这就是事情本该有的样子。但对于正在失去的东西，有一种焦虑。这里有一个有趣的社会转折，那就是20世纪初，美国反复出现恐慌，担心年轻人是否足够有男子气概，这其中之一正在发生，就像，哦，好吧，我们的美国年轻人，他们是否正在女性化？他们是否在户外花费足够的时间？他们是否参与了男性的追求？还是他们只是在读书、待在室内等等？这感觉像是对我个人的直接攻击。但我理解。是的。所有这些确实汇聚在一起，所有这些不是我想说汇聚在一起，而是它是推动
public parks and National parks and places where we can preserve the land both because we want to we want to have a sense of what America was like in the mythic past So we want to preserve what our forefathers saw But then also sort of like we want to make to make sure that the young men of the country can be exposed to the outdoors, can be exposed to physical activity. The Boy Scouts are founded during this time. We want to make sure that the young men of the country are engaged in the pursuits that will keep them manly and not unduly feminine. This is the time when more and more men are growing up never having had the experience
公共公园、国家公园和我们可以保护土地的地方的一部分，既因为我们想要，我们想要有一种对美国过去神话般的感觉，所以我们想要保护我们祖先所看到的，但也因为我们想要确保国家的年轻人能够接触到户外，能够接触到体育活动。童子军就是在这个时期成立的。我们想要确保国家的年轻人参与到那些能让他们保持男子气概而不至于过度女性化的追求中。这是一个越来越多的男人长大后从未有过
of cutting down a tree or something like that. Right. And it's time to get them back into knowing what that's like and what it's like to, I don't know, sleep outside. Things that people spent thousands of years trying to get away from. It's time to get back to those things. Or just like more Americans are living in cities, right? Living in cities, living in urban environments,
砍树之类的经历的时代。对吧。是时候让他们回到那种状态，知道那是什么感觉，知道在户外睡觉是什么感觉。人们花了数千年试图摆脱的东西。是时候回到那些事情了。或者只是更多的美国人住在城市里，对吧？住在城市里，住在城市环境中，
like the percentage of Americans who are engaged in agricultural work is like a low point at this time. And so there's all this sort of anxiety about sort of like, what's gonna happen to American manliness and masculinity if there's no frontier for kids, for young men to go to, to sort of like make their way, everyone's living in the city, that kind of thing. Getting soft. Yeah.
从事农业工作的美国人比例在此时处于低点。所以，对于如果孩子们、年轻人没有边疆去开拓、去闯荡，每个人都住在城市里，那种事情会发生什么，美国人的男子气概和男性气质会怎样，存在着各种焦虑。变得软弱了。是的。
And there's a bit of an evolution here of like open land in the beginning is sort of like part of a commons that's doled out, you know, not exactly fairly, but it's part of a commons for exploitation, because there's always more land land you can exploit it and use it to Whatever sort of industry you're trying to do and then there's this moment of like oh my god We need to conserve some of this to keep it as natural as possible because that's important to our character too and a little bit of Moses's evolution here is he's not trying to preserve the marshlands of Long Island so that there's a nice natural place
这里有一个演变，开放土地在开始时是作为一种公共资源的一部分，被分配出去，你知道，不完全公平，但它是为了剥削而作为公共资源的一部分，因为总有更多的土地你可以剥削并利用它进行任何你试图做的工业，然后出现了这种“天哪，我们需要保护其中一些，尽可能保持自然，因为这对我们的性格也很重要”的时刻。摩西在这里的一点演变是，他不是为了保护长岛的沼泽地，以便我们有一个好的自然地方
for us to go. He's a new kind of developer. He's a developer of recreation and attractions. And so when he means park, he doesn't mean this nice natural area. He means a thing of really great design and utility for the purpose of recreation. And yes, and very specifically, he means baseball diamonds. He means band shells. It's kind of halfway between being a soft city lad and being like a rough and tumble country boy is that you get to go out on the weekends and play baseball or, you know, or football or something in a park space during that time. And this is a big new idea for the reform element at the time in the state is this idea of land, not for conservation,
可以去。他是一种新型的开发者。他是娱乐和景点的开发者。所以当他提到公园时，他指的不是这种好的自然区域。他指的是一种为了娱乐目的而进行伟大设计和具有实用性的东西。是的，非常具体地说，他指的是棒球场。他指的是乐队演奏台。这介于成为一个软弱的城市小伙子和一个粗犷的乡村男孩之间，就是你可以在周末出去在公园空间里打棒球或足球之类的。对于当时州里的改革派来说，这是一个巨大的新想法，即土地不是为了保护，
but for recreation, that these are parks that are gonna have roads and facilities, like you're saying, they're gonna be designed things. And he asks for a bond issue of $15 million to fund state parks and parkways overseen by a proposed new state council of parks. And first he's got to win over Al Smith's idea. Al Smith, he doesn't really care that much about athletic recreation.
而是为了娱乐，这些公园将会有道路和设施，就像你说的，它们将是经过设计的东西。他要求发行1500万美元的债券，以资助由提议的新州公园委员会监督的州立公园和公园大道。首先，他必须赢得阿尔·史密斯的支持。阿尔·史密斯，他并不太关心体育娱乐。
He is not a guy who is, he's not a big sports buff. And he thinks the plan is too expensive. But Robert Moses knows, and this is something that will come up throughout the book too, that other people are attracted to this as well, but that Al Smith's particularly is attracted to big visual ideas. Show him a thing. Show him a made built thing. And that will impress him. And it's something that he can point to for the voters and say, look at this thing I've got made. This is look at the thing that we produced. If you elect me again, I will make more of those things that you can really improve people's lives in a visual way
他不是一个体育迷。他认为这个计划太贵了。但罗伯特·摩西知道，这也是整本书中会出现的事情，其他人也对此感兴趣，但阿尔·史密斯特别被宏大的视觉构想所吸引。给他看一个东西。给他看一个建造出来的东西。那会打动他。这是他可以向选民指出的东西，说，看这个我建造的东西。这是看我们生产的东西。如果你再次选举我，我将制造更多那些能以视觉方式真正改善人们生活的东西，
by building stuff. It's just very straightforward. There's an acronym that I've been trying to get off the ground in my private life, but I can't really for politics where my motto I want it to be, noticeably improve people's lives, which is Nipple. And it's the people I've tested it on, mainly my wife and my mom, think I need a new acronym. It's not, they don't love it. They don't love the Nipple acronym. But that's essentially what they're getting at here is noticeably improving people's lives, big visual things. And Moses wears Al Smith down and Al Smith goes, okay, but according to the law, I can only request one bond issue a year. I already requested one. And I'm not quite sure how the public is
通过建造东西。这非常直接。我一直在我的私生活中试图推广一个缩写，但在政治上我不能，我的座右铭我想是“显著改善人们的生活”（Noticeably Improve People's Lives），即NIPPLE。我测试过的人，主要是我的妻子和妈妈，认为我需要一个新的缩写。他们不喜欢它。他们不喜欢NIPPLE这个缩写。但这就是他们在这里本质上要表达的，显著改善人们的生活，宏大的视觉事物。摩西磨掉了阿尔·史密斯的顾虑，阿尔·史密斯说，好吧，但根据法律，我每年只能申请一次债券发行。我已经申请过一次了。而且我不确定公众
going to go with this because the price tag is so big. So I'm going to make a public statement saying that next year, I want to issue these bonds and we'll see how it goes over. And he makes a statement saying next year we should have this $15 million bond issue to build parks. And the immediate public response is enormous. People, it almost nearly unanimous. People love it. Everyone approves of building parks. There's no one who sees the downside to it. Parks are the best. Everybody loves them. Robert Caro, he goes back to Shakespeare's Julius Caesar to the park where Mark Antony is like,
会如何看待这个，因为价格标签太大了。所以我将发表公开声明，说明明年我想发行这些债券，看看反响如何。他发表声明说，明年我们应该发行这1500万美元的债券来建设公园。公众的直接反应是巨大的。人们，几乎是一致的。人们喜欢它。每个人都赞成建设公园。没有人看到它的缺点。公园是最棒的。每个人都喜欢它们。罗伯特·卡罗，他回到了莎士比亚的《尤利乌斯·凯撒》，回到了马克·安东尼说的那一幕，
not only was Julius Caesar gonna do these great things for you when he died, he left you all of his estates as parks and that's what makes the Romans go nuts. Now they miss Julius Caesar. People love parks. Like you can't, you just can't get over how much people love parks. They love the idea of it.
尤利乌斯·凯撒不仅要为你做这些伟大的事情，当他死时，他把所有的庄园都留给你作为公园，这就是让罗马人疯狂的原因。现在他们怀念尤利乌斯·凯撒。人们喜欢公园。就像你无法想象人们有多喜欢公园。他们喜欢这个想法。
And Al Smith, he knows good politics when he sees it. He knows that if, even if they're expensive, if parks are something people love, then that's a thing that will get votes. And Robert Caro goes into this description here of Moses' kind of comprehensive vision of Long Island in total as this working unit, this enormous development, and compares it to Walt Whitman's poetic vision of the area. He says basically, Walt Whitman's the only other person he can think of who has that kind of grand and universal of vision for this region. And most is not done. He's still roaming Long Island. He's still finding unused land. He goes to Fire Island and he's confused that the beach looks so much bigger
阿尔·史密斯，当他看到好的政治时，他知道。他知道，即使它们很贵，如果公园是人们喜欢的东西，那么这就是能赢得选票的东西。罗伯特·卡罗在这里对摩西将长岛作为一个整体工作单位、这个巨大的开发项目的全面愿景进行了描述，并将其与沃尔特·惠特曼对该地区的诗意愿景进行了比较。他说基本上，沃尔特·惠特曼是他能想到的唯一一个对这个地区有那种宏大和普遍愿景的人。而摩西还没完。他还在长岛漫游。他还在寻找未使用的土地。他去了火岛，他很困惑，因为海滩看起来比他的地图显示的要大得多，
than his map shows. And he remembers back to earlier when he was told that the ocean is always depositing new sand. It's been so many years since anyone mapped this area that there is 600 new acres of beach that nobody knew about, that is right here, that it's ready to use. And he's like drunk on the idea of land. He's just drunk on space and the ability to make these parks and on his own dreams. And Moses says, there's even more. We should do an even bigger system. More parks, bigger parks, a bigger parkway system. And Al Smith proposes making him the president
他回想起早些时候有人告诉他，海洋总是在沉积新的沙子。距离上次有人绘制该地区地图已经过去很多年了，那里有600英亩没人知道的新海滩，就在这里，准备使用。他就像对土地的想法喝醉了一样。他只是对空间和建造这些公园的能力以及他自己的梦想喝醉了。摩西说，还有更多。我们应该做一个更大的系统。更多的公园，更大的公园，一个更大的公园大道系统。阿尔·史密斯提议让他担任
of the Long Island State Park Commission. And Moses unsurprisingly accepts the job, because if he didn't, that's the end of the book. There's no book left. If he doesn't take the job, we don't have a book. There's no book. There's nothing there. But luckily, there is a whole lot of book there left. And we're going to start with the next bit. Chapter 10 after this. Okay, we're back starting with chapter 10. The best build Raptor in Albany, which is a short chapter, a very fun chapter. I love this chapter.
长岛州立公园委员会主席。摩西毫不意外地接受了这份工作，因为如果他不接受，书就结束了。没有书了。如果他不接受这份工作，我们就没有书了。没有书。什么都没有。但幸运的是，书里还有很多内容。我们将从下一部分开始。第10章之后。好了，我们回来开始第10章。“奥尔巴尼最好的法案起草人”，这是一个简短的章节，一个非常有趣的章节。我喜欢这一章。
It's a very important chapter. The title makes it sound like the worst of the tall tales and legends of the, of upstate New York's Adirondacks Mountains. It's like there's Paul Bunyan, there's the best bill drafter in Albany, gather round children. No one could draft bills better or faster than this man. Did he cut down trees or anything? No, he just was drafting bills all the time. Yeah, but he did it really well. And this is where really like his brains,
这是一个非常重要的章节。标题让它听起来像是纽约州北部阿迪朗达克山脉最糟糕的民间传说和传奇。就像有保罗·邦扬，有奥尔巴尼最好的法案起草人，孩子们围过来。没有人能比这个人更好或更快地起草法案。他砍树了吗？没有，他只是整天在起草法案。是的，但他做得非常好。这就是他真正像他的大脑，
his sort of, I don't know, deviousness and everything is coming together to give him the power that he needs to do what the rest of the book lays out. Yes, he is writing the law that creates the state council of parks, knowing that he writing the law that creates the state council of parks, knowing that he will be in charge of the state council of parks.
他的那种，我不知道，狡猾和一切汇聚在一起，赋予他执行书的其余部分所铺陈的内容所需的权力。是的，他正在撰写创建州公园委员会的法律，知道他将负责州公园委员会。
He's going to have that position. And so his job here is to write a law, not his job, it's his mission. No one said to him, write the law so you can be an independent power broker. But his mission, personal mission is to do just that. And so for instance, he says, well, we've organized the government,
他将拥有那个职位。所以他在这里的工作是写一部法律，不是他的工作，这是他的使命。没有人对他说，写这部法律，这样你就可以成为一个独立的权力掮客。但他的使命，个人使命就是做到这一点。所以例如，他说，好吧，我们已经组织了政府，
this state council has to be under the head of one of the preexisting departments. I'll put it in the conservation department and I'll say that the conservation commissioner submits my budget to the legislature, but a little bit farther down, I'm gonna write a law that says I prepare that budget and the conservation commissioner
这个州委员会必须在现有部门之一的领导下。我把它放在保护部门，我会说保护专员向立法机构提交我的预算，但再往下一点，我会写一条法律，说我准备那个预算，而保护专员
doesn't have anything to say about it. He just delivers it. And you know, obviously this is part of the executive branch. I have to be responsible to the governor, but I'm gonna make it so that my term is six years long, which is longer than the governor's term. So when there's a new governor, I get to stick around. I don't have to leave.
对此没有任何发言权。他只是提交它。而且你知道，显然这是行政部门的一部分。我必须对州长负责，但我会把它弄成我的任期是六年，这比州长的任期长。所以当有新州长时，我还能留下来。我不必离开。
And he's just putting in all these ways like that to give himself his own power and cement himself as an independent part of the government that other people don't have control of and cannot remove very easily. Yeah, like he's creating his own deep state, like the deep state of parks. Yeah, the deep park. Yeah. Like he's creating his own deep state, like the deep state of parks. Yeah, the deep park.
他只是在加入所有这些方式来赋予自己权力，并将自己巩固为政府的一个独立部分，其他人无法控制，也不能轻易移除。是的，就像他在创造自己的“深层政府”，公园的深层政府。是的，深层公园。是的。就像他在创造自己的“深层政府”，公园的深层政府。是的，深层公园。
Yeah. And he's doing all the things that like, I feel like we're warned about, about sneaky politicians. There's one more that I want to mention that is, because it feels so bonkers. And then I want to talk to Jamel about the stereotypes around this kind of thing. But he writes the bill using the word appropriation. And the legislators would have taken that to mean allocation of funds. That's the bill using the word appropriation. And the legislators would have taken that to mean allocation of funds. That's the only way they use appropriation.
是的。他在做所有那些我觉得我们被警告过的关于狡猾政客的事情。还有一件事我想提，因为它感觉太疯狂了。然后我想和贾梅尔谈谈围绕这种事情的刻板印象。但他用“拨款”（appropriation）这个词写了法案。立法者会认为这意味着资金分配。那是他们使用“拨款”的唯一方式。
You appropriate money for a thing. But then in the bill, it says that the term is used, quote, in the manner provided by section 59 of the conservation law. And just like you were saying, Jamal, that law is one that was passed in 1884. So that's 40 years earlier. And in that law, it provides for appropriation of land by a state official by walking onto private land and saying, I am now taking this land from you. And if you want compensation, come back to us later. And it's a method that hasn't been used in 30 years at that point. There was questionable constitutionality, but it's still on the books. It was never repealed. So it's still a law. Moses knows that law. Most of legislators don't. And there's just clause after clause in this bill that gives the spark council
你为某件事拨了款。但在法案中，它写道该术语的使用是“引用”了保护法第59条所规定的方式。就像你刚才说的，贾马尔，那部法律是1884年通过的。所以那是40年前的事了。在那部法律中，它规定州官员可以通过走进私人土地并说“我现在要从你手中征用这块土地”来征用土地。如果你想要赔偿，以后再来找我们。这是一种在当时已经30年没被使用过的方法。其合宪性存疑，但它仍然在册。它从未被废除。所以它仍然是一部法律。摩西知道那部法律。大多数立法者都不知道。在这个法案中，条款接一条款，赋予公园委员会
so much power, power to control roads, power to control, to have their own police force, power to basically write their own bylaws in parks. And he writes a thing in it saying that the commission shall have power to improve, maintain, and use lands of the municipalities, adjoining the parks and parkways of the commission with the consent of the local authorities having jurisdiction thereof. And since this is in Long Island, the legislators all say,
如此大的权力，控制道路的权力，控制、拥有自己警察部队的权力，基本上在公园里制定自己章程的权力。他在里面写了一件事，说委员会应有权在征得当地管辖当局同意的情况下，改善、维护和使用毗邻委员会公园和公园大道的市政当局的土地。由于这是在长岛，立法者们都说，
oh yeah, well, that means the local Long Island governments because they don't know a lot of this land is owned by New York City. So he doesn't have to get the consent of the local Long Island governments. He just asked the city and the city is like, Parkland for our residents, go for it. I don't care what happens to NASA County. Like just build the roads. And so he's managed to kind of hide all these things in there.
哦，是的，嗯，那是指长岛当地政府，因为他们不知道这些土地中有很多是纽约市拥有的。所以他不必征得长岛当地政府的同意。他只是问了市政府，市政府就像是说，为我们的居民提供公园用地，去吧。我不在乎拿骚县会发生什么。就像只要修路就行。所以他设法把所有这些事情都藏在里面了。
And the question I want to ask you was, I feel like it's been a stereotype in American politics for, I don't know, 200 years that politicians are kind of like slimy folks hiding things in bills to do favors for people or to get things for themselves. And it feels like Robert Moses is really doing that here in order to make this parks committee as powerful as possible or parks council. I keep using council commission and committee interchangeably when I know they're not. They mean different things that I don't know the definitions of. I apologize to council members, committee members, and commission members who are listening to this. We're very frustrated by it.
我想问你的问题是，我觉得在过去200年里，美国政治中一直有一种刻板印象，即政客们就像是那种滑头，在法案中隐藏一些东西来为别人谋取利益或为自己谋取私利。感觉罗伯特·摩西在这里确实是在这样做，为了使这个公园委员会或公园理事会尽可能强大。我一直在交替使用理事会、委员会和委员会，尽管我知道它们不是一回事。它们意味着不同的东西，但我不知道它们的定义。我向正在听这个节目的理事会成员、委员会成员和委员们道歉。我们对此感到非常沮丧。
But how often do you know of this kind of thing really happening where someone is really hiding things in bills, knowing that by the time anyone finds out it's going to be too late? Is that a really thing that happens or is this out of the ordinary? This is unusual only because it's such a singular person doing it. This is kind of an unusual case of a singular guy being like, I know I'm gonna be in this position and I wanna make sure that I can accrue
但是，你真正知道这种事情发生的频率有多高？有人真的在法案中隐藏东西，知道等到有人发现时已经太晚了？这真的是会发生的事情吗，还是这很不寻常？这很不寻常，只是因为这是一个如此独特的人在做这件事。这是一个相当不寻常的案例，一个独特的人说，我知道我将处于这个位置，我想确保我能够积累
as much authority to myself as possible in a way that no one's really gonna notice. And that's, I can't think of it happening all that often. Cause usually a bureaucrat like that isn't in a position to write laws, right? Like usually a bureaucrat like that isn't in a position to write laws, right? Like usually a bureaucrat like that is in the executive branch and they may have influence on writing laws, but they may not be able to directly write the law themselves. That's like, that's, that's what we call like a separations of power problem.
尽可能多的权力，以一种没人会真正注意到的方式。而且，我想不出这种情况经常发生。因为通常像那样的官僚并没有处于起草法律的位置，对吧？就像通常像那样的官僚并没有处于起草法律的位置，对吧？就像通常像那样的官僚是在行政部门，他们可能对起草法律有影响力，但他们可能无法直接自己起草法律。那就像，那，那就是我们所说的权力分立问题。
Like you don't want, you don't necessarily want the person charged with executing a law to be the one writing the law. The more common is executives, whether they're at the state level or the federal level, creatively reading existing laws for the sake of doing things they want to do. Maybe the great example with the is like the Emancipation Proclamation, right? With like the Lincoln essentially saying, I'm, you know, this category of person, these are contraband, and the law gives me the legal authority to seize enemy contraband. And so I'm saying that all states in rebellion, because the Lincoln administration does not recognize the Confederacy as a thing, legally, according to the White House, the Confederacy
就像你不一定希望负责执行法律的人成为起草法律的人。更常见的是行政人员，无论是在州一级还是联邦一级，为了做他们想做的事情而创造性地解读现有的法律。也许最好的例子是《解放黑人奴隶宣言》，对吧？林肯基本上说，我，你知道，这类人，这些是违禁品，法律赋予我扣押敌方违禁品的法律权力。所以我说所有处于叛乱状态的州，因为林肯政府在法律上不承认邦联是一个实体，根据白宫的说法，邦联
does not exist. These are just states in rebellion. I can confiscate contraband in the states of in rebellion under the existing legal authority I have. That's not just a creative reading of like existing law, right? Like, I mean, that's way more common than someone writing the law itself to give them basically a bunch of secret power that no one anticipated. Okay, well, I feel good knowing
并不存在。这些只是处于叛乱状态的州。我可以在现有的法律授权下没收处于叛乱状态的州的违禁品。这不仅仅是对现有法律的创造性解读，对吧？我的意思是，这比某人自己起草法律来赋予他们基本上是一堆没人预料到的秘密权力要常见得多。好吧，知道这一点
that this is out of the ordinary. Yeah, that's a little less common. In part because lawmakers are very jealous of their power to write laws. Like they don't want other people to do it. So it's very clever and sneaky. Robert Moses put himself in a position to be the guy to write the laws.
是不寻常的，我感觉很好。是的，这稍微少见一些。部分原因是立法者非常嫉妒他们起草法律的权力。他们不想让其他人这样做。所以这非常聪明和狡猾。罗伯特·摩西把自己放在了起草法律的人的位置上。
There's some of that kind of, I guess setting himself up for those interpretations also, where he talks, in one section, it talks about the bill giving the commission power over parks. And then another section, it defines parks as including parkways, boulevards, docks, piers, bridges, entrances to parks. And it says the state law on highways says counties can veto highways and their borders. But that law doesn't mention parkways. So he specifically makes sure that they are labeled as parkways. And that's one of those readings where I'm like, okay, I mean, it's a, it's
有一些那种，我想说是为那些解释做准备，他也谈到了，在其中一节中，它谈到了法案赋予委员会对公园的权力。然后在另一节中，它将公园定义为包括公园大道、林荫大道、码头、栈桥、桥梁、公园入口。它说关于公路的州法律说县可以否决公路及其边界。但那部法律没有提到公园大道。所以他特别确保它们被标记为公园大道。这就是那些解读中的一种，我当时想，好吧，我的意思是，它是
roads, right? Like the idea that, that a highway in a Parkway are such totally different animals that the counties can veto one another. The other seems like an interpretation, you know? Yeah. I mean, that kind of politics and bureaucratic maneuvering rewards, like people who are really into being the biggest patents you can imagine. And we're finally answering this question that, you know, Robert
道路，对吧？就像认为公路和公园大道是完全不同的动物，以至于县可以否决一个而不能否决另一个，这似乎是一种解读，你知道吗？是的。我的意思是，那种政治和官僚操纵奖励了那些真正热衷于成为你能想象到的最大专利持有者的人。我们终于回答了这个问题，你知道，罗伯特·
Carroll started in the very beginning, you know, like when we talked to him and he's like a reporter at Newsday and he's like, he's, you know, he hears Robert Moses being mentioned in something. And then he looks up his title and it's like New York City Parks Commissioner. Why is he building roads and, you know, like housing developments in all these places if he's the Parks Commissioner?
卡罗在最开始时提出的，你知道，就像我们和他交谈时，他是一名《新闻日报》的记者，他听到罗伯特·摩西在某事中被提及。然后他查了他的头衔，是纽约市公园专员。如果他是公园专员，为什么他在所有这些地方建造道路和，你知道，住房开发项目？
And it's like, this is it. Like he answered the question. This is how, because he's managed to call everything a park. A road is a park. Just look at subsection C of clause nine. You'll see that Parks Commissioner is defined as God Emperor of New York. Yeah, it's kind of it.
就像是，就是这样。他回答了这个问题。这就是原因，因为他设法把一切都称为公园。一条路就是一个公园。只要看看第九条的C小节。你会看到公园专员被定义为纽约的上帝皇帝。是的，差不多就是这样。
Yeah, clearly this isn't a park, Mr. Moses. If you look at the section after it, you can see parks can be defined as the internal organs of people I don't like. And so that's why I've been removing the kidneys of people who get in my way. It's legal. It's all there in black and white. I guess we should have read the law. But luckily for Moses, nobody reads the law.
是的，显然这不是一个公园，摩西先生。如果你看它后面那一节，你可以看到公园可以被定义为我不喜欢的人的内脏。所以这就是为什么我一直在切除那些阻碍我的人的肾脏。这是合法的。一切都在黑纸白字上写着。我想我们应该读读法律。但幸运的是，对于摩西来说，没有人读法律。
Nobody reads it before it's introduced to the legislature. The people who run the small parks in the state, Moses is like, hey, this is just going to be like a coordinating agency. You guys are still going to control your own little parks. So will you support me in this? They go, certainly. And that's a lie. It's just an outright lie.
在法案提交给立法机关之前，没有人读它。那些管理州内小公园的人，摩西就像是说，嘿，这只是一个协调机构。你们仍然会控制你们自己的小公园。那么你们会支持我吗？他们说，当然。那是一个谎言。这完全是一个彻头彻尾的谎言。
And Moses hands selects to introduce the law a state assembly member representing the North Shore. I named F. Truby Davison, which Truby is an amazing middle name for the guy who is kind of the political novice who represents rich people. He is a wealthy 22 year old. He is so impressed to be in a room with Al Smith.
摩西亲自挑选了一名代表北岸的州议会议员来引入这项法律。我叫F·特鲁比·戴维森，特鲁比对于那个代表富人的政治新手来说是一个很棒的中间名。他是一个富有的22岁年轻人。他能在阿尔·史密斯的房间里感到非常荣幸。
He doesn't really know what he's doing. He doesn't read or study the bill. On April 10th, 1924, he introduces it. It passes by unanimous vote with no debate. And then Robert Carroll depicts Moses as being so impatient for Al Smith to sign this bill, probably because he's worried someone's going to read it before Al Smith gets around assigning it into law. And finally, eight days later, Smith signs the bill.
他真的不知道自己在做什么。他不读也不研究法案。1924年4月10日，他引入了它。它以全票通过，没有辩论。然后罗伯特·卡罗将摩西描绘成对阿尔·史密斯签署这项法案非常不耐烦，可能是因为他担心在阿尔·史密斯签署成为法律之前有人会读它。最后，八天后，史密斯签署了法案。
He immediately appoints Moses president of the Long Island State Park Commission, which makes him a part of the state council of parks. The state council of parks, Alexi Mitz chairman. And as Caro ends this chapter and this part, part three, he says, at the age of 35, Robert Moses had power and no sooner did he have it than he showed how he was going to use it. Oh, that's where we leave off. He's got the power finally. Finally, he's broke ring power.
他立即任命摩西为长岛州立公园委员会主席，这使他成为州公园委员会的一员。州公园委员会，亚历克西·米茨担任主席。正如卡罗在这一章和这一部分，第三部分结束时所说，35岁的罗伯特·摩西拥有了权力，他一拥有权力就展示了他将如何使用它。哦，这就是我们离开的地方。他终于有了权力。终于，他正在操纵权力。
It's so good. So much of this book feels at times like a, like each chapter is the end of an episode and I'm like, all right, well, how are they going to get me excited for the next episode? And then they do it. And I'm like, wait, how's he going to use that power? I know. I just, I just watched the movie executive decision and there's a scene or a
太棒了。这本书的很多内容有时感觉就像，每一章都是一集的结尾，我当时想，好吧，他们将如何让我对下一集感到兴奋？然后他们做到了。我当时想，等等，他将如何使用那种权力？我知道。我刚看了电影《最高危机》，有一个场景或
character says the president's going to have to make an executive decision. And this is, this is what this feels like, you know, probably the only time that, that, that a Steven Segal movie or I guess really a Russell movie, right? Has been compared to a, compared the Power Broker, but still. It reminds me of the end of that last section where we said, what about parks? It kind of reminds me of like every dumb ass Easter egg in the Star Wars prequels, you know,
角色说总统将不得不做出一个行政决定。这就是，这就是这种感觉，你知道，可能是史蒂文·西格尔电影或我想真的是拉塞尔电影，对吧？第一次被拿来与《权力掮客》相比较，但仍然。这让我想起了上一节的结尾，我们说，公园怎么样？这有点让我想起《星球大战》前传中每一个愚蠢的彩蛋，你知道，
where they're like trying to give some little backstory here and you're like, oh, I know what that means, I know. Oh, that's where Han Solo got his jacket. I was what that means. I know. Oh, that's where Han Solo got his jacket. I was wondering that. But yet there's a, he's, Robert Carras has done such a good job of setting up. This guy is going to take parks, and he's
他们试图在这里给一些小背景故事，你就像是，哦，我知道那意味着什么，我知道。哦，那是汉·索罗得到他夹克的地方。我当时在想那个。但我还是，他，罗伯特·卡拉斯在设定方面做得非常好。这家伙要接管公园，他
going to use them to reshape the city. And so as we see him getting closer and closer, it's even though I know where it's going, I know that it's going to a place that is going to be very bad for certain people, for thousands of people, as they are forcibly removed from their homes in his later projects. I'm still like, there's the excitement of seeing him come to fruition. And the fact that when we started this episode, he was 30 years old and he seemed like a has been. And now he is 35 years old and he is approaching the apex of this
要用它们来重塑城市。所以当我们看到他越来越近时，即使我知道它要去哪里，我知道它要去一个对某些人，对成千上万的人来说非常糟糕的地方，因为他们在后来的项目中被强行从家中赶走。我仍然觉得，看到他实现目标的那种兴奋感。事实上，当我们开始这一集时，他30岁，看起来像个过气的人。现在他35岁，他正在接近这种
power that he's going to wield for the next 40 years as one of the most important people in the in the northeastern United States. It's very exciting. It's a, yeah, it's a real Star Wars prequel thing where it's like, oh, Anakin, he's becoming more and more like Darth Vader. I'll say it's always striking to me just to see how young people are, right? Like 35 years old and sort of. Yeah, it makes me very mad, yeah.
权力的顶峰，他将在接下来的40年里作为美国东北部最重要的人之一来行使这种权力。这非常令人兴奋。这是一个，是的，一个真正的《星球大战》前传的东西，就像是，哦，阿纳金，他变得越来越像达斯·维达了。我总是觉得很震惊，看到人们是多么年轻，对吧？就像35岁，某种程度上。是的，这让我很生气，是的。
About the wheel, a tremendous amount of authority. And that to me is always quite striking. Yeah, it's also what's striking about this moment is there's only one person in the world who knows how powerful he is at this moment. And that's Robert Moses. Only he's the only one who knows how powerful he is at this moment. And that's Robert Moses. He's the only one who knows how powerful he has made himself. And that is just a great moment of just, I don't know, like, I don't know, like the end of Clockwork Orange or something, you know, like when you
关于轮子，拥有巨大的权力。对我来说，这总是相当令人震惊。是的，这个时刻令人震惊的还有，世界上只有一个人知道他在这个时刻有多强大。那就是罗伯特·摩西。只有他是唯一知道他在这个时刻有多强大的人。那就是罗伯特·摩西。他是唯一知道他把自己变得有多强大的人。这只是一个伟大的时刻，我不知道，就像，我不知道，就像《发条橙》的结尾之类的，你知道，就像当你
look into his eye and you see, you know, like he knows what's going on, you know, like, you know, it's just really an intense moment. And I love it. I love the trauma of it. Yeah. That sets us up for part four, the use of power, which we will not get into in this episode. But, uh, it's going to be very exciting. This is it. Look, Moses versus the North Shore Barons. Moses is going to start getting corrupt. He's going to make his dream a reality.
看着他的眼睛，你看到，你知道，就像他知道发生了什么，你知道，就像，这真的只是一个紧张的时刻。我喜欢它。我喜欢它的创伤。是的。这为第四部分，权力的使用，做了铺垫，我们不会在这一集中深入探讨。但是，呃，这将是非常令人兴奋的。就是这样。看，摩西对阵北岸男爵。摩西将开始变得腐败。他将使他的梦想成为现实。
He briefly gets involved with boxing in a way that is not totally straightforward. You know, he's only very brief. He's got power. He wants to build things. And to do that, he's going to have to start breaking things like rules, because he is the power broker rule breaker. There's only so I mean, it's only so exciting, I can make the make it a certain point. Well, that's that is on the next time. So, uh, Jamal, thank you so much for joining us. And, and like, I hope that we've, you know, spoiled enough of this to convince
他短暂地以一种不完全直接的方式参与了拳击。你知道，他只是非常短暂。他有权力。他想建造东西。为了做到这一点，他将不得不开始打破规则，因为他是权力掮客规则破坏者。只有这么多，我的意思是，只有这么多令人兴奋的，我可以让它达到某一点。好吧，那是下一次。所以，呃，贾马尔，非常感谢你加入我们。而且，而且像，我希望我们已经，你知道，剧透了足够多的内容来说服
you to pick up the rest of the power broker and or at least follow along with us listening, if, if nothing else. If there's an audio book of this, I think I might pick up the power broker to listen to at least because I am, I am genuinely fascinated by kind of bureaucratic maneuvering and like legislative maneuvering. It's, it's fascinating to me. Oh, you will get your fill. You will love it.
你拿起剩下的《权力掮客》和/或至少跟着我们听，如果，如果什么都没有的话。如果这有有声书，我想我可能会拿起《权力掮客》来听，至少因为我，我真的对那种官僚操纵和立法操纵很着迷。这，这对我来说很迷人。哦，你会得到满足的。你会喜欢的。
It's 66 hours. The audiobook is actually very good. The Robert Ceddin is the narrator. He has extremely good diction, so you can speed that sucker up so you can get through it. I tend to go back and forth when I redid it. I went back and forth and read some parts and then took the dog on a walk and listened to some. And it's a good way to get your power broker
它是66小时。有声书实际上非常好。罗伯特·塞丁是叙述者。他的发音非常好，所以你可以加快那个家伙的速度，这样你就可以读完它。我重读时倾向于来回翻看。我来回翻看并读了一些部分，然后带狗去散步并听了一些。这确实是一个获得你的权力掮客的好方法
in for sure. I should do that because I have to admit I have my two copies of the book, my signed copy that I will not let my children touch, and then my working copy that I write notes in. And I will frequently find myself reviewing it by reading it in bed before I go to bed. And it's such a big book that it like hurts my tummy when it's resting on it. Like it's not really comfortable to rest on my stomach. So the audiobook might be the way to go for me. And notoriously, there is no ebook version of this, which a lot of people on our Discord have complained about. And they're like, you think maybe the presence of this book club will make them put out an ebook version?
肯定。我应该这样做，因为我必须承认我有我的两本副本，我不会让我的孩子们碰的签名版，然后是我在上面写笔记的工作副本。我经常发现自己通过在睡觉前在床上阅读来复习它。它是一本如此大的书，以至于当它放在上面时，它会伤害我的肚子。就像它放在我的肚子上真的不舒服。所以有声书对我来说可能是最好的选择。而且众所周知，这本书没有电子书版本，我们在Discord上的很多人都抱怨过。他们就像是，你认为这个读书俱乐部的存在会让他们推出电子书版本吗？
In a way, like perversely, I actually, I never want to see an ebook version of it. I really wanted to be this big tome that you have to carry. You know, what I love, what I love most about is when I was carrying around reading it the second time, I would rest it on the passenger seat of my car. And it weighs enough that the car thinks, I need to buckle the seat belt of the passenger seat because it just sets off the alarms. It's a human sized book. It's a person sized book.
在某种程度上，像反常地，我实际上，我从来不想看到它的电子书版本。我真的希望它是这本你必须携带的大部头。你知道，我最喜欢的是，当我第二次带着它阅读时，我会把它放在我车的副驾驶座位上。它的重量足以让车认为，我需要系好副驾驶座的安全带，因为它只是触发了警报。这是一本人类大小的书。这是一本真人大小的书。
And I love that about it. Jamel, where can people find you, like listen to your podcast, all that sort of stuff, let's do that. You can find me usually twice a week at the New York Times. I have my weekly column that runs on Tuesdays and Fridays most of the time. We also have a new blog at New York Times for opinion.
我喜欢它这一点。贾马尔，人们可以在哪里找到你，比如听你的播客，所有这些东西，让我们做那个。你通常可以在《纽约时报》每周找到我两次。我有我的每周专栏，大多数时候在周二和周五运行。我们还在《纽约时报》有一个新的博客用于评论。
And so sometimes I post on that. And that's like my job. That's like my main job. And so, I mean, honestly, a lot of people don't necessarily understand, I mean, they think that, oh, you write for the New York Times sometimes and then you do other stuff. Like, no, like my full-time job is writing that column. That's, that's how I can afford to go to the dentist. I have this podcast, Unclear and Present Danger, with my friend John Gans, who is also a writer. And we watch the political and military theaters, like the post-Cold War period of the 90s. Otherwise, you can just find me around the internet Internet I don't know. I'm on tiktok
所以有时我会在上面发帖。那就是我的工作。那就是我的主要工作。所以，我的意思是，老实说，很多人不一定理解，我的意思是，他们认为，哦，你有时为《纽约时报》写作，然后你做其他事情。就像，不，就像我的全职工作是写那个专栏。那就是，那就是我如何负担得起去看牙医。我有这个播客，Unclear and Present Danger，和我的朋友约翰·甘斯一起，他也是一名作家。我们观察政治和军事剧院，就像90年代冷战后的时期。否则，你可以在互联网上找到我，互联网，我不知道。我在TikTok上
I've been on Elliot's other podcast the flop house That's right. Jamela's the flop house is politics and hedgehogs Correspondent was on our episode for Sonic the Hedgehog and our episode for Andy the talking hedgehog So we're looking forward to having you back for Sonic the Hedgehog too. I guess I just Yeah, that's the other larger purview. But yeah, that's the only other hedgehog movie. I'm sure there'll be others. Hedgehogs, I guess, are popular. I don't know. So that's where you can find me. Yeah. Tell me a little bit about this, this TikTok outlet that you have, because I don't use TikTok very much, but I mostly just see you on it.
我上过埃利奥特的另一个播客《The Flop House》。没错。贾马拉是《The Flop House》的政治和刺猬通讯员，参加了我们关于《刺猬索尼克》和我们关于《安迪，会说话的刺猬》的那一集。所以我们期待着你回来参加《刺猬索尼克2》。我想我只是，是的，那是另一个更大的范围。但是是的，那是唯一其他的刺猬电影。我相信会有其他的。刺猬，我想，很受欢迎。我不知道。所以这就是你可以找到我的地方。是的。告诉我一点关于你拥有的这个TikTok渠道，因为我不怎么使用TikTok，但我大多只是在上面看到你。
And it's great. And it's sort of an interesting and maybe not intuitive place for good political discourse, but you bring it there. How did you stumble upon it? How do you use it? Like, how's that working? So I've been in journalism for About 13 years now and the entire time my thinking though has been whenever there are new social platforms It's worth trying to get familiar with them just because I don't know what who knows what's gonna happen
而且它很棒。它是一种有趣且可能不直观的良好政治话语场所，但你把它带到了那里。你是怎么偶然发现它的？你是怎么使用它的？就像，它运作得怎么样？所以我从事新闻业大约13年了，我一直以来的想法是，每当有新的社交平台时，都值得尝试去熟悉它们，仅仅因为我不知道，谁知道会发生什么
It's nice to be able to translate what I do to maybe a different kind of medium. What I think I do is think about contemporary American politics with an eye towards broader American history. Very often, I'm not, you could believe or think what you want, but it's worthwhile to know the specifics and the actual mechanisms at work here. Some of this is pushing pushing against, you know, things I like to call folk civics, like ideas about the way government works that have no real relationship to reality, but are like a good story that we've told ourselves are true. Some of this just relates to sort of straightforward American history. There was a period where I was like constantly doing videos about why Abraham Lincoln really did a post slave. Like really trying to impress some people like, no, this is really, this is like actually a very significant thing that is true.
能够把我所做的事情翻译成可能是一种不同类型的媒介是很好的。我认为我所做的是思考当代美国政治，着眼于更广泛的美国历史。很多时候，我不是，你可以相信或想你想要的，但了解这里的具体细节和实际机制是值得的。其中一些是在推动，推动反对，你知道，我喜欢称之为民间公民学的东西，就像关于政府运作方式的想法，它们与现实没有真正的关系，但就像我们告诉自己是真的好故事。其中一些只是涉及某种直接的美国历史。有一段时间，我一直在做关于为什么亚伯拉罕·林肯真的做了后奴隶的视频。就像真的试图给一些人留下深刻印象，不，这真的是，这就像实际上是一件非常重要的事情，是真的。
So why do you think we have to reset a narrative about Abraham Lincoln? Like I have this hypothesis and I think narrative journalism plays a role in this, that it is our tendency as humans to revise narrative sort of, like in surprising ways especially. And so you grow up, you know, and you think, well, Abraham Lincoln freed the slaves, there's no argument there.
那么你为什么认为我们必须重置关于亚伯拉罕·林肯的叙事？就像我有这个假设，我认为叙事新闻在其中发挥了作用，即作为人类，我们倾向于以某种方式修改叙事，就像，以令人惊讶的方式，特别是。所以你长大，你知道，你认为，好吧，亚伯拉罕·林肯解放了奴隶，这一点没有争议。
And then there's like this impulse to forward the story in some way that complicates it and makes it different and develops it and maybe eventually even makes it counterintuitive. And then we have to reconnect to the original story again. What is that impulse? I'm so curious about it. No, I think your initial explanation actually is a lot of it.
然后就像有一种冲动以某种方式推进故事，使其复杂化并使其不同并发展它，也许最终甚至使其反直觉。然后我们必须再次重新连接到原始故事。那种冲动是什么？我对此很好奇。不，我认为你最初的解释实际上是其中的很大一部分。
We get these stories and these ideas and these often this, and then we learn more, and it challenges and shatters our previous conceptions. And so we think that we, I think make the totally reasonable and rational supposition that for anything that even seems like a little good in the past, in the past especially, there must be some complicating factor to show that either it's actually bad, or even if the result is good, the intention was bad. And with Lincoln in particular, I mean, Lincoln's sort of a perfect subject for this precisely because he's sort of like the great secular American saint, right?
我们得到这些故事和这些想法，这些通常是这个，然后我们学到更多，它挑战并粉碎了我们之前的概念。所以我们认为我们，我认为做出完全合理和理性的假设，对于过去，特别是过去，即使看起来有点好的任何事情，也必须有一些复杂的因素来表明要么它实际上是坏的，或者即使结果是好的，意图也是坏的。特别是对于林肯，我的意思是，林肯某种程度上是这个的完美主题，正是因为他某种程度上就像伟大的世俗美国圣人，对吧？
Like he's like the, you know, he's the guy for whom, you know, he's unimpeachable. And then people learn, right? They learn that, you know, through much of his career, he supported colonization of blacks. They read the letter he wrote the horse freely and which says, you know, if I could save the union without freeing a single slave, I would. And it all builds up as like a circumstantial picture for like, oh, well this guy was totally insincere and he was a politician and blah, blah, blah. And the hard thing is actually kind of, the thing that's actually kind of hard to communicate is that like at the same
就像他是，你知道，他是那种，你知道，他是无可指责的人。然后人们学习，对吧？他们了解到，你知道，在他职业生涯的大部分时间里，他支持黑人殖民。他们读了他写给霍斯·弗里利的信，其中说，你知道，如果我能不解放一个奴隶就拯救联邦，我会的。这一切都建立起来，就像一个间接的画面，就像，哦，好吧，这家伙完全不真诚，他是一个政客，等等等等。而困难的事情实际上有点，实际上有点难以沟通的事情是，就像在同一
time, all of those things are not, they're totally true. But then you read more about the guy's life and the politics, and it becomes also, it's also very clear that this is a guy who has a deep sees opposition to slavery, and is negotiating that through the world of like, for him, contemporary American politics. How do I act as a guy who's against slavery in a political context where most people don't really actually care that much? And people who care a lot are some of my putative political allies.
时间，所有这些事情都不是，它们完全是真的。但随后你读了更多关于这家伙的生活和政治，它也变得，也非常清楚，这是一个对奴隶制有深刻看法的人，并且正在通过像，对他来说，当代美国政治的世界来协商这一点。我如何作为一个反对奴隶制的人在一个大多数人实际上并不真正关心这一点，而关心很多的人是我名义上的政治盟友的政治环境中行事？
That's a more interesting story. And it's less clear cut. I think people want the story to be neater than it is, but it's not. I was talking about this on TikTok, actually, with regards to the LBJ. LBJ probably a racist. It's not really that hard to... You know? Pretty straightforward.
那是一个更有趣的故事。而且它不那么明确。我认为人们希望故事比它更整洁，但它不是。我实际上是在TikTok上谈论这个，关于LBJ。LBJ可能是一个种族主义者。这真的不难……你知道吗？相当直接。
Wouldn't be surprising. Right, yeah. LBJ also a sincere believer in civil rights. And the two things are both true. And there's a tendency, I think, in American culture to want everyone to be one thing or the other. And we have a very hard time with dealing with sort of like contradiction and dealing with sort of like oftentimes major political figures being both at the same time. Like I feel like my thing on TikTok is sort of like emphasizing this again and again and like emphasizing why this is important to take seriously and what the lessons of this might be.
不会令人惊讶。对，是的。LBJ也是民权的真诚信徒。这两件事都是真的。我认为在美国文化中有一种倾向，想要每个人都是这样或那样。我们很难处理某种矛盾，也很难处理某种通常主要的政治人物同时是两者的情况。就像我觉得我在TikTok上的东西某种程度上就像一遍又一遍地强调这一点，并强调为什么认真对待这一点以及这可能带来的教训很重要。
Yeah. I mean, certainly the story of Robert Moses as Robert Carroll tells it in The Power Broker is a story full of nuance and you know some noble motivations and some terrible motivations and some and you know He's a complex figure and when you get to like the Lyndon Johnson books whoa, Nelly I mean is it is real mess of nuance to tell you the truth It's it's it's kind of crazy the whole message of the Lyndon Johnson books seems to be, a bad person can do a good thing sometimes. And asking the question, is it worth all the bad things that it took to get that good thing eventually? And with Power Rooker, it's almost the opposite where it's like,
是的。我的意思是，当然，罗伯特·卡罗在《权力掮客》中讲述的罗伯特·摩西的故事是一个充满细微差别和，你知道，一些高尚的动机和一些可怕的动机的故事，而且，你知道，他是一个复杂的人物，当你读到林登·约翰逊的书时，哇，天哪，我的意思是，说实话，这是一个真正的细微差别混乱。这，这，这有点疯狂，林登·约翰逊书的全部信息似乎是，一个坏人有时可以做一件好事。并提出这个问题，为了最终得到那件好事所付出的所有坏事是否值得？而对于《权力掮客》，它几乎是相反的，就像，
this guy could do bad things too, but he might do some good things along the way. Or a good thing could turn out to be a bad thing, a bad thing maybe could turn out to be a good thing. We can never know anything. That's why I always turn to the power broker for all my answers. And also the power broker in and of itself is this gigantic tome of revisionist history. Like people had a very different concept of Robert Moses before this book started.
这家伙也可以做坏事，但他可能在过程中做一些好事。或者一件好事可能变成一件坏事，一件坏事也许可能变成一件好事。我们永远无法知道任何事情。这就是为什么我总是转向《权力掮客》寻求我所有的答案。而且《权力掮客》本身就是这本巨大的修正主义历史大部头。就像人们在这本书开始之前对罗伯特·摩西有一个非常不同的概念。
And then after this book came out, really everything changed. That's exactly right. That literally before this book came out, unless you had done the specific research into the life of Robert Moses, or you had been affected personally by Robert Moses' work, you thought of him just as,
然后在这本书出来之后，真的什么都变了。完全正确。这字面上是在这本书出来之前，除非你对罗伯特·摩西的生活进行了具体的研究，或者你个人受到了罗伯特·摩西工作的影响，否则你只认为他是一个，
he's that good guy who built the parks. He seems great. He didn't even want money. He's amazing. And Robert Carrows book changed that story completely to the point that we are now currently in this wave of revisionist revisionism, this post power broker world where you have books coming out saying, well, actually Robert Moses was the only guy who could get things done and you need a giant city planner who
他是那个建造公园的好人。他看起来很棒。他甚至不想要钱。他太棒了。而罗伯特·卡罗的书完全改变了那个故事，以至于我们现在正处于这股修正主义修正主义的浪潮中，这个后权力掮客世界，你有书出来说，好吧，实际上罗伯特·摩西是唯一能把事情做成的人，你需要一个巨大的城市规划师，他
will push people around like not even chess pieces like like, you know, tiny ants or something like that. And there's just no end to that cycle. I'm looking forward to when I'm an old man and power broker two comes out and it is the revisionist take on that revisionist take. I guess that's just the one of the wonderful things about human nature is that you always want to prove your previous generation wrong. And the next you always want to prove your previous generation wrong. And the next generation always wants to prove you wrong. And maybe history moves a little bit forward at the same time through that process. Over the years, certain other reassessments and some criticisms of the book have sort of bubbled up to the surface.
会像推人一样推人，甚至不像棋子，就像，你知道，微小的蚂蚁之类的。那个循环没有尽头。我期待着当我是一个老人的时候，《权力掮客2》出来，它是对那个修正主义的修正主义看法。我想这就是人性中奇妙的事情之一，即你总是想证明你上一代人是错的。而下一代人总是想证明你是错的。也许历史通过那个过程同时向前移动了一点。多年来，这本书的其他一些重新评估和一些批评已经浮出水面。
And we're going to actually talk about some of those, I think, over the course of the year as we go through the parts of the book. But I have to say that most of them are not as compelling to me as the book The Power Broker. It's difficult. It's such an amazingly written book. Robert Carroll put so much work into it. He has documents to back up everything he's saying. That's right. It's a real, if you come at the king, you best not miss type scenario where he's, it seems like anything you can come up with, he's like, well, when I talked to the guy who did that, this is what he told me. Or when I looked at the document, no one else has ever seen, but I'll show it to you now. This is what it said.
我想我们实际上会在这一年里，当我们浏览书的部分时，谈论其中一些。但我必须说，其中大多数对我来说不如《权力掮客》这本书引人注目。这很难。这是一本写得如此令人惊叹的书。罗伯特·卡罗在其中投入了大量的工作。他有文件来支持他所说的一切。没错。这是一个真正的，如果你来找国王，你最好不要错过的情况，他，似乎任何你能想到的，他就像，好吧，当我与做那件事的人交谈时，这就是他告诉我的。或者当我查看没有人见过，但我现在会给你看的文件时。这就是它所说的。
So to undermine the power broker would take it in a truly effective way, would take such an enormous outlay of energy and time and patience, the kind of thing really only Robert Caro has in it. That's right. That's like you need a Robert Caro to take on Robert Caro. It's like the old story where Sherlock Holmes creates Moriarty because he needs an opponent worthy of his skills. Robert Caro would have to put on a mask or something and become, you know, dark Caro
所以要以一种真正有效的方式破坏《权力掮客》，需要投入巨大的精力和时间与耐心，这种事情真的只有罗伯特·卡罗才有。没错。这就像你需要一个罗伯特·卡罗来对付罗伯特·卡罗。这就像那个老故事，夏洛克·福尔摩斯创造了莫里亚蒂，因为他需要一个配得上他技能的对手。罗伯特·卡罗将不得不戴上口罩之类的东西，成为，你知道，黑暗卡罗
and go after his own work so that he could stop himself. I wish that I had any other cultural frame of reference besides superheroes. I feel like I brought them up so many times in this episode. Well, we can figure out some way to incorporate superheroes. And the next part of the book is part four, the rise to power this chapters 11 through 15. So get out your books, turn on your audible, whatever it, however you consume your power broker, get on that. And we'll talk about that next month. If you're yearning for even more power broker discussion, we have a whole Discord server with like 1400 people have already joined the Discord server. We'll link to the website and we'll also have a link inside the show notes. There's been really a ton of fun discussion going on. We'll also have a post on the show notes. There's been really a ton of fun discussion going on.
并去追求他自己的工作，这样他就可以阻止自己。我希望除了超级英雄之外，我有任何其他的文化参考框架。我觉得我在这一集中提到了它们很多次。好吧，我们可以想出某种方法来结合超级英雄。书的下一部分是第四部分，权力的崛起，这是第11到15章。所以拿出你们的书，打开你们的Audible，无论它，无论你们如何消费你们的《权力掮客》，开始吧。我们下个月会谈论那个。如果你渴望更多的《权力掮客》讨论，我们有一个完整的Discord服务器，像1400人已经加入了Discord服务器。我们会链接到网站，我们也会在节目笔记中有一个链接。真的有很多有趣的讨论正在进行。我们也会在节目笔记中有一个帖子。真的有很多有趣的讨论正在进行。
We'll also have a post on the 99% visible subreddit so you can talk about the power broker there to your heart's content. If you enjoyed this episode and you thought, I wish I could hear Elliott talk more, but this time I want him to talk about stupid things. Then why not check out my other podcast, The Flop House. It's America's original bad movie podcast. Probably my co-host, Stan McQuain Stewart Wellington, have been doing it with me for a long time now. Also, I have a couple
我们也会在99%可见的subreddit上有一个帖子，这样你就可以在那里尽情谈论《权力掮客》。如果你喜欢这一集，并且你认为，我希望我能听到埃利奥特多说一些，但这次我想让他谈论愚蠢的事情。那么为什么不看看我的另一个播客，《The Flop House》。它是美国最初的烂电影播客。可能我的联合主持人，斯坦·麦奎恩·斯图尔特·惠灵顿，已经和我一起做了很长时间了。另外，我有几个
other things starting in April. You can pick up a comic series called Hercules from Dynamite Comics. It's based on the Disney film of the same name. It's also completely unrelated to the power broker. But luckily, I have two books I'm working on now that should hopefully be out not too long after this show finishes One is a book about joke writing from the University of Chicago Press It's called joke farming and the others a children's picture book from Harper kids called Sadie mouse recs the house Those books are still being made, but I guess write yourself an email set it to arrive in your inbox a year from now Reminding you to buy those two books. I'd really appreciate it.
其他事情在四月开始。你可以拿起一套名为《大力神》的漫画系列，来自Dynamite Comics。它基于同名的迪士尼电影。它也与《权力掮客》完全无关。但幸运的是，我有两本书我正在写，希望在这个节目结束后不久就能出来。一本是关于笑话写作的书，来自芝加哥大学出版社，它叫《笑话耕作》，另一本是来自Harper Kids的儿童绘本，叫《萨迪老鼠拆房子》。那些书还在制作中，但我猜给自己写一封电子邮件，设置在一年后到达你的收件箱，提醒你买那两本书。我会非常感激。
They are not related to the Power Broker. I apologize. It is perfectly fine. The 99% of visible breakdown of the Power Broker is produced by Isabel Angel. It's edited by Committee, Music by Swan Real, and Mix by Tara Hirsch. 90 APIs, Executive Producers Kathy too, our senior editor is Delaney Hall. Kurt Colested as the digital director of the rest team includes Sarah Bake, Chris Baruppet, Jason De Leon, Emmett Fitzgerald, Gabriella Gladney, Martine Gonzalez, Christopher Johnson, Vivian
它们与《权力掮客》无关。我道歉。这完全没问题。《权力掮客》的99%可见分解由伊莎贝尔·安吉尔制作。它由委员会编辑，音乐由斯旺·里尔创作，由塔拉·赫什混音。90 API，执行制片人凯西·图，我们的高级编辑是德莱尼·霍尔。库尔特·科莱斯特德是数字总监，其余团队包括莎拉·贝克、克里斯·巴鲁佩特、杰森·德·莱昂、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、加布里埃拉·格拉德尼、马丁·冈萨雷斯、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、薇薇安
Lay, Lodge Madawn, Jacob Maldonado-Medina, Kelly Prime, Joe Rosenberg, and me, Roman Mars. The 99% of his logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. The art for the Power Broker series was created by Aaron Nester. We are part of the Stitcher and Series 6M podcast family, now head toward Six Blocks North in the Pandora building. In beautiful, uptown, Oakland, California. You can find links to other Stitcher shows I love as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. at 99pi.org. But now when someone brought up the subject, Smith said,
莱、洛奇·马道恩、雅各布·马尔多纳多-梅迪纳、凯利·普莱姆、乔·罗森伯格，还有我，罗曼·马斯。99%可见的标志是由斯特凡·劳伦斯创作的。《权力掮客》系列的艺术是由亚伦·内斯特创作的。我们是Stitcher和Series 6M播客家族的一部分，现在前往潘多拉大楼的北六个街区。在美丽的，上城，加利福尼亚州奥克兰。你可以在99PI.org找到我喜欢的其他Stitcher节目的链接以及99PI的每一集过去节目。在99pi.org。但现在当有人提出这个话题时，史密斯说，
the best build drafter I know is Bob Moses. I cannot get a good New York accent. This is ridiculous. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我知道的最好的法案起草者是鲍勃·摩西。我无法获得好的纽约口音。这太荒谬了。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。